this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
one minute please always remember to
switch the lights off we're ready for
safari sorry everybody you know
sometimes these happen hello everyone
my name is Taylor mccurdy and well on
camera with me today is David and
welcome to the sunset Safari bushwalk
we're gonna walk
are we ready to find some animals I am I
promise I promise I'm ready now we've
had some interesting things today we've
played cricket that was a lot of fun i
won
just thought I'd let you know no I'm
just joking I was terrible and Geraldine
got caught up twice by Amanda chef she
tried to redeem herself and came back
and failed - no it's not sherry for
those of you have never joined us on one
of these wonderful Interactive's safaris
will hopefully find you some ants but
you can talk to us you can hashtag a
safari live on Twitter or you can talk
to us via the YouTube chat and comment
away on Facebook and hopefully we'll
find them now looking onto the drainage
line just on the other side is get a go
pan where squirrels monkeys Franklin's
have been alarming all day long I wonder
who's looking just on the other side but
you'll have to wait to find out or if
you go to Ralph
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome aboard another sunset Safari
you're watching Safari live and we're
watching what seems to be maybe an
african hawk eagle getting chased by a
little folktale drongo
I think it was that but we are only
looking at the silhouette now and please
don't forget that we are in the juma
traverse of the graduate Kruger National
Park in South Africa my name is Ralph
Kirsten and on the camera this afternoon
we've got since I has it since I please
don't forget to join us on the hashtag
Safari laughs on Twitter and on the
YouTube live chat send us your questions
and your comments and get involved on
the largest game Drive in the world now
it is a lovely warm afternoon little bit
of a breeze started to come through
seems like that eagle has been chased
off by that little folktale drongo and
well we're gonna start up again and
maybe head down towards the twin dams
area as well as treehouse dam which is a
little bit on the southern side south
central side of the juma traverse we are
on the lookout as usual for all the
normal usual suspects such as lion and
leopard as since i is sitting there
listening intently to me because well
we're always looking for that but it's
nice and hot now in the afternoon so
it's normal that they could be just
relaxing in the shade a little bit lying
nice and flat there's a little bit of
potential for them to be up in the trees
we've got some clouds around so it might
cool off quite substantially a little
bit later but for now nice and warm as I
said we are feeling the humidity a
little bit that well while we carry on
our search let's head back to Tyler
who's got Zazu well Ralph you probably
know this hornbill it's one of our
friends that live around in camp and I
thought why not introduce you to all the
camp characters on this wonderful Sunday
afternoon so this is one of the
yellow-billed hornbills that we have not
named yet wolfy flies and he's quite
relaxed and
he's just trying to feed and all the
leaf litter we got there picking up
something well shall we see how close we
can get the ones that that live inside
Kent are really quite entertaining
because like I said this morning you
literally have to step on their tail
feathers for them to fly away
maybe this hornbills not from here
perhaps I've just mistaken him for
someone else Hey oh there's the other
one yes and actually I've just said the
same thing to David about Esmeralda the
spotted emerald spotted would death
remember we're talking about her she was
at the car park not so long ago so we're
gonna see if we can find it she cause
she or he there very relaxed hello
little Hormel you see oh there's the
red-billed hornbill - so we've got most
species but no partners today normally
we see them in pairs so there's about
four to six of them that fly around and
chase one another like I said they go
for the disco ball very very often
perhaps we'll have to show you the disco
ball that might be a good on my find
Esmeralda at the fire pit
preparing the bonfire for tonight now
mm-hmm
they recently just cleared that area
Malaika we are lucky and I'm sure you're
a pretty envious there is literally just
wildlife everywhere like I said hookah
Maureen was he was probably only a
couple of meters away from from those
rooms that I was well it wasn't even my
room that I was in you know it was
Kristin's room we just hijacked it but
look at this hello
I mean when we're out there we don't
normally get to get this close to the
animals on foot and they recently just
cleared here I think they're going to do
a bit of bit of work on the fence line
so it's made for a perfect spot the
soils nice and soft so they can dig
through all that leaf litter quite
easily and I'm sure from well all the
workers that were here and well doing
their thing I've obviously turned up a
few grubs and beetles every may be
trying to hide away so they're very
happy hello you're not being even closer
just watching us every now and then
so you'll see basically what we've got
going on over here this is our general
carpark this is a fence that really just
tries to keep the elephants and lions
and then
I said we can close the gate there and
we have an electric wire on the way
around but it doesn't stop the Leopards
they come walking right past you all the
time they're dwarfed mongoose liked to
play on our chair too
it's quite fun he's quite happy to just
hop as close as it really wants to and
if you were to just stand you out would
probably just come right at your feet
hello what you're doing enjoying an
afternoon snack I'd have to know what
they were thinking we might get the
yellow-billed humble flying back in
again David you know what I've just
realized I think we've just stumbled
across four greatest sandpaper raisin
ever to be in the sabi sand I'm not even
joking excuse me birds coming through oh
my goodness I'm not even joking hmm look
that wasn't a nice one
I'm being unladylike let's see no either
so terrible have you tried them I'm
really disappointed not because every
time we see sandpaper raisins ants in
the bush we're very excited because of
the delicious fruit come in Mouse I was
trying to describe the taste to you a
couple of days ago and normally they're
very juicy these ones however a quick
dry they're not very nice at all and I'm
so disappointed maybe they're we're a
bit late yeah no that's also not nice ah
literally I've never been so excited in
my life for a fruit but we didn't win
this time around well they're not very
nice little which would maybe explain
why the birds and things are not eating
them it's not really there isn't really
any flesh at all on these seeds look at
that completely dry I don't want to eat
that that's no good now someone else
that's in the area driving about about
looking for a leopard is Steve
good afternoon everybody welcome my name
is Tim Falconbridge joined on camera by
mr. Craig is Emmett and we are art
indeed in the wilderness
we heard monkeys alarm calling about an
hour and a half ago just here close to
us sort of north west of North the camp
around the small little Gallagher pan
just had little scratch around in the
area but there's no tracks
apparently hukum or either the visiting
male leopard or there the potentially
new male leopard of the area was left
somewhere sort of north of here this
morning and monkeys do not lie when
their long-haul monkeys don't lie so
it's possible that they saw him and he's
in the drainage line of this so we're
just gonna keep along a little bit see
if anything comes out on the road
sure the others have told you please
feel free to send to your questions
hashtag Safari live let us know what you
would like to see and discuss this
afternoon after all this is an
interactive live Safari and we wouldn't
do it if it wasn't for the viewers out
there so let us know what you'd like to
see and hopefully we can cater for it
it's a beautiful day 26 degrees Celsius
80 82 I think Fahrenheit so a very nice
and a relatively cool afternoon it was
overcast this morning with the potential
for rain but we never got wet never got
wet rained in certain places for any
outside the reserve but thankfully we
didn't get wet it is a little bit
strange to have rain this time of year
but the vegetation definitely enjoys it
Linda you would like to see tanyon cup
well that would be sensational to see
them we are not in the area at the
moment maybe you're off we'll go over to
that area I'm going to spend a little
bit of time over here and failing that
decile most definitely go towards the
east and see if we can pick up on any
any more tracks I know Taylor had some
tracks this morning I'm not a hundred
percent sure where they were we did walk
into that area this morning and then
with looming rain that we decided to
slowly start moving back so we never on
the bush walk never found any of those
tracks and not had a personal way but I
have an idea have an idea hello Ashley
you would like to see lines you don't
want to know what the chances well
there's always a chance Ashley you know
we are an open reserved and though
fences between us and all the reserves
around in the kruger park and these
animals they just come and go you know
we can wake up in the morning and there
can be lions there generally speaking
the cats move in at night or early
morning when it's a little bit cooler
but only two three weeks ago I came out
of Drive just like this herd monkeys
alarm calling went down to the damn
waterhole just off to our western side
now or southern side now and installed
two of the Birmingham a big male lion so
these things can happen there's nothing
preventing cats from just walking in and
doing their thing nothing at all nothing
at all it's not common to see cats
moving in the day but bearing in mind
two days ago I think James was following
up on the sticks prod who were just over
here and then they moved about this time
so it happens you know
it happens if they're thirsty or if
they're moving in response to whatever
they could be moving in response to then
that is what happens so this is live we
cannot predict what will happen next so
there's every possibility of seeing
lions
I wouldn't mind showing you a lion or
two
okay well pink Taylor has got something
up her sleeve something unpredictable
it's quite unpredictable right you're
Lee in the courtyard now catch Davi I
wasn't a very good throw this is our
bonfire pit so this is where we normally
stand around we hold hands and we sing
songs with one another it's really quite
nice like you all know camp is really
just one big happy family family we
don't do any fire walking or anything
like that so don't worry also the fire
is art but now this is the prized
possession of the wild earth Juma camp
it's the disco ball and how do we make
it spin suppose you might as well this
is also the water back that lives in
camp I don't never stick so I'm gonna
have to use a to spin it there you go
normally it spins a little bit but I had
to climb all the way up top there you
may also notice that there's a torch
that is a tough touch - I had a headlamp
that is attached to the tree that goes
on and then at night you can imagine
it's just so beautiful and sparkly Lily
you like the paintings on the wall I
think it feels like we're in Mozambique
sort of when we are when we're around
here that's because we have sand as well
that's quite nice so you can see why we
have so many animals in camp the warm
wolves come down and do what they were
doing outside the dwarf mongoose often
playing around here and then the
starlings like I said they normally take
a perch up one or the other the other
yes sit on the lower branches come with
me
Cosi says I'm gonna show you where
Gregory lives are you ready for this
we're gonna be careful cuz there's also
a Mamba that lives here a sandbank you
remember the sand bags from the deluge
yes you will remember that very well
here they are still doing well this is
where Gregory lives now I wish I had a
bright enough headlamp because mine is
not working so well but Gregory goes
inside there looks like somebody's been
walking here actually I think Gregory's
come out today I can see a track on
either side very gracefully coming
through yet it was a nice warm day so it
wouldn't surprise me as Arden about
just catching up on some feeding I don't
think she likes us anymore because she
doesn't come to visit very often and
then little Gregory who's Robert jr.
went down inside there too and then like
I said there's a snake and squirrels and
all sorts of things that live around
here
so yes close this to keep the bushwacker
now apparently somebody else is also
lingering around Kent but it wasn't me
well we're getting closer to twin dams
I've just passed triage dam very quiet
there and now heading down towards twin
dams and then I think because it's this
time of the day it's still quite warm
it's it's like I said a little bit
earlier this is a little bit of gusty
breeze coming through every now and then
but you know through all of my
experience at this time of day regularly
you get elephants coming down to drink
you can also have the Predators coming
down too you have that midday drink but
it's not generally the real active part
of the day the Predators are mean
elephants can be a perfect time and in
different national parks around southern
Africa it's always been one of my go-to
kinds of things to say to my guests when
we arrive at a and a camp or you know a
place in the early morning or towards
midday I always say go down to the water
hole and wait I'm pretty sure you're
gonna have some elephants come down and
drink and they're always used to think I
was the elephant whisperer because you
know it's just looking at different
animals activity during different
seasons and different times of the day
as well and elephants generally do like
to go down to water holes in the mud day
to go and get their nice big thirst
quencher and before heading out into the
afternoon and going feeding once again
normally quite active in the morning and
then that midday all going down to the
water and then sort of calming off in
the early part of the afternoon before
they start to feed again gangs right
through into the night as it cools off
again
generally very good time to hit down to
the water these times of day all through
the year with elephants and obviously
with the Predators now as we going into
winter and we do have you know cooler
afternoons you can have more activity
from them during the day obviously they
do have the most part during the night
but very good chance of spotting
predators it's just coming down for a
drink or being active as well more so in
winter in summer
mostly they do rest up during the heat
of the day specially if it's hot and
humid that combination is it's quite a
killer not only for for humans you know
I often think if I feel really sluggish
a lot of the animals with especially
higher metabolism generally will feel
the same if not worse now just coming
down here towards twin dams it doesn't
seem like there is much happening here
so my next feeling is if I was an animal
blocka always say if you want to catch
fish you need to think like a fish so if
I was an animal out here in this kind of
a day I think I'd be locked to hanging
in them Watty or drainage line or last
big trees with is a bit of fruits around
the jackal berries are in fruit at the
moment also the brown ivories the
quarry's and so it's normally a good
spot to go into and as I say there's
twin dams very quiet there for the
moment but we just got to put ourselves
in the right spots and keep on doing
that we're gonna get something exciting
jumping out at us a little bit of
patience and perseverance and I'm sure
we're gonna have a very good afternoon
say nothing happening there for now now
don't forget to send us any of your
questions and your comments and if you
want me to focus on any topics in
particular if you've got any kinds of
thoughts that you want to share with us
on this wonderful day out on safari then
please just send it through and I will
do my best to focus on those subjects or
chat about them and see how we can just
get the debate going see also the russet
bush will have fruits fruiting up not my
at at the moment
and so our canal search is gonna
continue out along here I've got a very
good feeling there's something around
the next corner
there was some requests well the Jim
well everybody welcome to the boots and
Betty's Jim it's lovely
it's a makeshift gym but we can well add
work so here we have our mats which we
will roll out what are we gonna do now
bicycles Jerry can I don't know it's all
falling apart yes
Andrea Mumba does live in Kent I don't
worry about that and actually these
rings over here I'll pull the gentlemen
normally they are a lot higher like I'm
sure you've all seen the gymnasts doing
it I'm not gonna do it for you if you
ask nicely Conrad will come out and show
you this is no okay
well Conrad's there inside hiding right
he doesn't want to come out in the show
but no there's something very important
that I want to show you
well Chad it's one last thing and then
we're going out into the wilderness is
looking at ponds this is Tina
you can see she has her name on it
a little pot who's this something to do
with the naming of the plants if she did
that and then I completely understand
they live outside final controls at the
moment killing them so the presenters
come on every now and then and we have
all we have a look actually know anybody
with a green thumb comes our chair has
the water the plants down normally we
have to do this because they've over
watered do that anyway so we're gonna go
and see if we can find some elephants
out on the open plains maybe a giraffe
if we're lucky someone that will have
better luck finding animals is Ralph as
Pumbaa and the family of little piglets
start to disappear off onto the bank of
the Milwaukee and my feeling was quite
correct I'm going to find quite a lot of
animals down here in the Milwaukee I
believe nice little drainage lon lots of
cool areas lots to feed on as well for
herbivores and then that for me is also
gonna lead predators down here as well
look at these little piglets we are now
almost on a level with him and how many
was that since I think it was for pig
let's say 9 1 2 3 4 you know they've
disappeared around the corner a little
bit but nice little family of them and
it seems like cuckoo Marie the male
leopard oh and here comes an ass male
neeyala a bull is crossing the drawer of
a bed
he's a good-looking chap and they are
one of the most elegant of all the
antelope I would say you see how he's
got those lovely white tips to his horns
as well let's showing that he is into
his prime he is a fully grown matured
adult bull in Yala and he's just
enjoying his time a little bit with
these warthogs no a little bit nervous
of them and sometimes they just trig a
each other
the pigs run off and inside the Antelope
also get a little bit skittish that's
why I've come down here because I do
feel that this is the place to be when
it's nice and warm so I'm gonna continue
on our little slow little ramble along
there I'm watching here pill spotted owl
it's calling and it's been wonderful
inside the search I think who Komori was
around this morning I think it was
Taylor that found him steve is also
looking for him and I wonder how that's
going
did he hear that first spotted outlet
calling I heard it the search so far for
hookah Modi is has not drawn any
conclusions nothing on the road kind of
found the area where the vehicles that
were with him a little bit turning
around and all that sort of thing but I
think he's right in there by the pan in
the depression close to the lodge and I
know that there's some guests have just
checked in so going to give them a half
now and our asoto sort of vacate their
rooms before I end up getting accused of
peeking so I'm sure he's probably right
in there in the depression right next to
one of the rooms and I don't want
someone to think that there's this guy
with binoculars stalking around outside
my room that wouldn't go down very well
especially if you're a paying guest so
we'll just give them a little while to
come out of camp I saw the vehicles
arriving just shortly after or while we
were leaving to go on Drive so I think
there's some new guests checking in and
I'll just wait for for one of the guides
to come on the radio and then I'll know
good we can go and have a look but I am
sure hookah would he would enjoy if
there is warthogs that Ralph has showed
you he does enjoy as you have seen on
countless occasions he enjoys himself a
little bit of pig and I wonder if they
are related to the one from the other
day if there were four of them it's
possible two adults two youngsters shame
they get over it pretty quickly though
and in the moment it's pretty pretty
traumatic but there seems to sort of
just carry on with life the next day
hello Bobby on TV show in February Noel
had who camera kilowatt again very
shortly afterward to kill the Steinbach
he's stolen a push back from from ting
ganas he didn't kill that but I haven't
personally seen him with any other type
of meat have you Craig
who's he newcomer him surely he surely
is had in the parlor or two but we just
don't see it unit does also spend a lot
of time in the West we don't know what
he does that side but I have no doubt he
is a very efficient in parlor hunter as
well talking about hunters and catching
fish Ralph has got someone who's an
expert and this is a little brown hooded
Kingfisher one of the resident
Kingfisher that stay here some of the
other ones that do stay here the giant
Kingfisher as well as the pied and so
he's always around but these are
predominantly insectivorous kingfish's
as opposed to the pod and the giant who
are pretty much passive oars eating
mostly if not only fish you know and I'm
not gonna say that anybody's experience
is wrong but in my experience with brown
hooded kingfishers I've seen them
catching insects next to the water and
I've also seen them bombing into the
water but not headfirst now actually if
you watch them very closely they bomb
their body into the water and not in a
fishing mode merely as a boss so they
just splash themselves and then they fly
up onto the branch and they splashed
himself again and they flop onto the
branch mostly down to further
maintenance and helping to get rid of
some of the dust and the oil from the
preen gland but I have heard other gods
saying that they have witnessed them
fishing but through my experience when
I've looked at them very closely I
believe that what they're doing when
they're splashing in the water is
literally just that
having a nice little splash and this
brown hooded Kingfisher I've found here
on numerous occasions and I think he's
probably got a nest if not just roosting
up in one of these trees here and he's
always yeah so it's lovely to come and
see him quite regularly but it's always
difficult with birds to watch them
Monique in London you say that you love
kingfishers I do too they normally very
brightly colored and well the brown
hooded Kingfisher isn't as elaborate
coloration as for instance the woodland
Kingfisher or the little tiny pig me or
malachite king fishes which are really
beautiful blues and reds but well this
is one of the residents and he just
keeps himself a little bit more of a low
profile I would say and does have a lot
of competition when all the migratory
kingfish's returned now in Britain I
think in London well maybe in the canals
and so on I think and you can correct me
if I'm wrong which king fishes do you
get there I think you get the malachite
and I think you might even get the pied
but you can you can correct me I don't
think you get the giant Kingfisher and
there might be one or two others but I'm
pretty sure that you do get the
malachite Kingfisher in Europe along
those little canals and so on catching
all those little fish but I'm pretty
sure they would migrate don't they uh
not too much about it so please share
with us let me know send us your
comments about the kingfishers in the
different parts of the world because
it's always interesting to learn about
different birds from wherever you are
and so we'd love to know and if you've
got some photos well send them into the
hashtag Safari log on Twitter
we'd love to see any of those because
it's normally quite difficult as well to
get especially them in flight or
catching any fish bombing into the water
it would be lovely to see your photos
and showcase your skills
right mr. insectivorous kingfisher its
head on we'll leave you to it he did
just actually catch it seemed like a
muscle something that was flying on the
ground there we just missed it but he's
gonna sit on that branch and stay there
while we carry on down the low Watchi
and carry on our search for all sorts
everything and Alice and I think we're
not the only one that's doing exactly
that
yes we are and probably the worst
section of road around and you've come
just in time to experience it with us
it's just a small little piece bumpy
hold on to your hats we ran up on
Easterns tides but first boundaries on
the other side here we've done a big
loop around
hold on Craig oh here we go through it
some of the roads surely for example
this one would be very very old
management road and so wouldn't have
been designed with the in interest of
being driven very regularly or for game
drives so lots of elephant activity it
allows to find some elephants there's
been loads of tracks in and out coming
up and down there is a dam on the other
side of the road here time Bertie dam
it's just north of us
no darts that is where they're going to
be drinking
as we head back in towards Schumer
itself towards via Teller water and Hall
and close to Gallagher we're still
looking for some tracks we switch off
every now and again to see if we can
hear any alarm calls but clearly if it
was with Cameron he's probably stopped
moving and when a leopard stops moving
he's not spotted by anything and they
get away with them being quite easily
concealed
sure mama leopards can go through a
fence no fence can stop a leopard to be
honest
national parks game reserves that I've
got fences the fences do not stop the
leopards they do go through them they
can dig or go I know or sometimes even
go over there very very versatile cats
so there's nothing really keeping them
out of camp apart from their fear of man
and Jerry walking back from her little
house just the other night but we think
she'd do the female right there by the
vehicles so and they've had I think it
was Rebecca and cursed had husana right
next to the room as well and we have a
hyena that comes into camp every single
night so yeah leopards do come and go
but they don't see us as prey and so
they're not really looking for us but
they move through you know they do know
that there's niala and day care that
like to sort of secret themselves in and
around the camp because we've got a
quite nasty wooded vegetation area or or
River drainage depression nearby so
there would be some small antelope
hiding in the thickets there and we find
cats moving through there quite
regularly well whether we see it or not
we often find the tracks of where
they're been moving and we believe huka
moody is in a very similar sort of place
okay are we going to continue on here
see if we can find anything of interest
while we do taters got something it is
mightily interesting
well it is quite interesting because we
found some termites and they're rather
large termites you can see that one
that's moving around now I think it must
be a soldier it is almost double the
size of the of the other termites who
are suspected probably workers you can
see a couple of them now David is
actually there's a whole lot of them I
wonder if you can see them through yeah
I wish I'd actually brought my torch out
Oh silly that I didn't there's normally
with termites there bill there well they
start their colonies underground of
course some of the species will utilize
and feed on wood and that's exactly
what's going on over here they under I'm
not sure what species we've got I think
we're standing on a developing termite
mound most of it I think is underneath
the ground and it seems like an elephant
or someone has been rubbing up against
this tree and strip the bark off of it
because there's all sorts of sorts of
damage here and there's a couple of
fresh pieces that have been pulled off -
maybe even a wildebeest or a zebra could
have come up and had a scratch on this -
and it's fairly loose it's very very
loose I mean now just touch that and you
saw how it all shook so I don't think
that they living up in here I think that
they might just be trying to more feed
on the wood that's really really cool
how big that is now you wouldn't want
one of those to bite your finger because
those massive mandibles will pack a
serious punch and that's their sort of
first defense there is that if they feel
like they asked threatened or if
something comes around like an aardvark
and starts digging down into the earth
they're going to latch on it every sort
of angle from the ears to the tip of the
snout and hopefully that will be painful
enough for the AH drug to move away all
whatever it may be that's feeding on
them I've had one of them bite me before
it was horrible
it drew blood on my hand and your hands
are fairly tough - then they go back
inside so I wonder if those soldiers
aren't around they'd only she seemed
bothered with us at one point I thought
they were all gonna run away but there's
a whole lot of them I mean here's some
more they're all working here but every
time the wind blows a lot of the soil
that has been taken up yet small starts
to drop down - so I don't know how long
they've been in here for it seems quite
hard I'm just feeling sort of the
the soil it's cooler but a very
interesting structure now I don't think
that this is just home to termites I
think that there are lizards and things
and possibly some scorpions living here
too I'm sure
snakes we've actually just been trying
to find some of those critters so we'll
start looking so I want to stick my face
anyway where something's going to jump
out and dry and get me but there's so
many little crevices and yet even for a
squirrel as an emergency it could
probably hide underneath a piece of bark
like this but I'm trying to think I
don't think I've ever seen a snake in
here I don't think we've ever found a
scorpion on here before there are a
couple of trees that we can check where
we've seen scorpions before that seem to
be hotspots and we'll try and have a
look for some of them today - it's
really pretty in here I'd love to be
that small that I could crawl around on
the inside of the bark and into all
sorts of little crevices that's really
wonderful
they don't seem to be too active they're
moving around a little bit but I mean I
can't see if they're feeding they're not
collecting anything someone walking
others are just sitting in the Sun the
soldiers are just marching about those
two in there are very busy
kind of interesting sorry dubby and any
it takes them a very very long time to
start the building amount but sometimes
what happens if the Queen dies of one
colony and eventually the entire colony
will disappear with it and a new colony
or a new l8er can move on in so after
you've had a lot of rain then we'll see
the princes and princesses so the winged
termites will fly off once they find a
mate they lose their wings and they go
down into the east and they can continue
in all termite mound but mmm some of
these bigger ones that we see are
probably in excess of 50 years old maybe
even a little bit more than that so so
it all depends on how long the Queen
will survive for that's beautiful right
it's not someone is taking it easy this
afternoon it's Ralph and he's on a
sunset cruise
yeah well I'm just just making my way
along them lo wotty and it's it's
wonderful in this drainage line and I
was about coming through yeah because it
often reminds me of driving in Namibia
in those ephemeral rivers and this is a
seasonal River it's not flying
underground but there's a ephemeral
rivers that you get in Namibia very
similar to this kind of seen here
there's another little Kingfisher on the
branch you can have a quick look at him
if it's the same as the one before we
having a country show afternoon saying
that you don't get the malachite
oh the Pied Kingfisher only the common
Kingfisher in Western Europe that's
interesting because I thought that there
was a malachite but I'll stand corrected
so well done thank you for that the
common Kingfisher does it have elaborate
colors because I was always under the
impression that the malachite or maybe
that common Kingfisher is a malachite
looking Kingfisher as well now this one
is about 500 metres away from the last
one that we saw ah you're saying that
you get the sacred Kingfisher in New
Zealand and that sounds very interesting
do you know why it is sacred Aaron
because we've got the sacred Ibis here
in South Africa and pretty much right
across Africa wherever there's quite a
lot of water around because there are
also predominantly you know around
wetland areas marshy areas and the
reason they're called sacred Ibis a
little bit of topic with the kingfishers
but you're talking about your sacred
Kingfisher the sacred Ibis is called as
such because in Egypt
yeah and they they had there were making
plantations of all sorts and I think it
was mainly around rice where they had
they failed in a couple of seasons with
their crops and they thought it was
because the sacred Ibis who moved around
in those sort of wetland areas where
they planted their crops were eating all
the seeds and as a result they started
to kill all the sacred Ibis
obviously weren't called that at the
time and they killed all of them but
what they found out after that was there
was a very big increase in bahasa and
that's where they actually realized that
the sacred Ibis was feeding on
freshwater snails which is the host
animal of the the virus that that gives
you both hacia so once they worked that
out it was one of the Pharaohs who
whoever was in charge he said to them
right from now on we will be protecting
this bird because it's helping us with
the sickness of bahasa I don't think
that they probably called it that at
that time but that's sickness anyway
waterborne disease with the house being
the freshwater snail we leave this bird
now because he's helping us with this
disease and from now on he will be known
as the sacred Ibis and so that nobody
would then touch that bird off to that
so that's the reason for the sacred Ibis
but what's the reason for the sacred
Kingfisher that's the question Aaron so
send it through if you know if you don't
if anybody else does well let us know
and that little Kingfisher he's
obviously bobbing his head up and down
and left to right do you know why they
do that there's a question for you while
I continue on my drive why do birds a
lot of hunting birds as well as lizards
why do they Bob the heads up and down
and left to rot and since I was now
doing the jiggy-jiggy in the back there
while I'm saying this but a lot of birds
and reptiles do that what is the reason
for it I will give you the answer a
little bit later
we'll try some fun some more birds that
are exhibiting that behavior and it's a
very interesting reason why they do that
but some other animals that live up in
the trees don't pop their heads and
seems the tail is found one of them
look at this little critter not open a
tree for a change we're having luck with
squirrels on termite mounds today this
one apparently was seen by David and
James not so long ago just the other day
and David said something interesting to
me do you think they think it lives in
this termite mound it honestly would not
surprise me as to where a squirrel would
find a home I think a unoccupied termite
mound would be a great spot to sort of
sleep in although they do prefer trees
but maybe it just means that stay around
your pets as this is its day sleeping
area but if I was a little mammal like
that to anything I think I'd also be
sitting on that little mound enjoying
the last of the afternoon Sun there's a
bit of the wind picking up so maybe
we're in for a chilly night so the best
you warm up I'm surprised we haven't
seen more squirrels today let's take a
little so we just pretend like we're not
walking towards the squirrel and we will
it's gone we'll see we're gonna go
towards this tree you see you can get a
little bit closer maybe it comes back up
because there's another hole up in this
in this tree over here and so Bobby what
importance what ecological importance do
squirrels have well I suppose
squirrels are firstly the prey species
so a lot of animals rely on them so from
Eagles to well snakes and things like
that they're all feast upon squirrels
squirrels also I would imagine has
something and something to do with them
the dispersal of seeds or car far marula
nuts end up traveling not even anywhere
near where where they were fun they'll
take them to all sorts of places so I
think the help of dispersing seeds they
don't eat all the nuts in the end and
what else could a a squirrel do let me
think I don't I'm sure there's a whole
lot of different things not sure but
they're very important everything out
yet is exceptionally important I just
want to check this tree to see if this
is actually a hole in the tree or if
it's just there that's just deceiving
not I think it is so I wonder if the
squirrel actually isn't living up in
here as well well has the second sort of
Hafs
it's really big wondering oh you see
just up there it's all hollowed out
looks like they awesome termites that
have been they've been having a go at
this tree - it's not very nice but
definitely a nice spot for the all the
squirrel to live in exciting some ants
crawling around anyways it's got safety
here - if it needs to climb I go from
the ground and go all the way up to the
top but listen
yes there is a candy I'm not sure what
that was if they're I don't know why the
can is nailed to the tree for the
elephants what does that do to the
elephants I think they were trying to do
some research project on elephants are
not really sure anyways perhaps that was
their favorite favorite cool drink who
knows they were trying to find out what
cool drink elephants prefer what soda
elephants prefer so I've actually seen a
couple of other things around but I'm
not really sure it looks like it's been
mowed yet don't you think looks like
somebody has actually come with a big
lawnmower but it hasn't no one has been
Eureka's and most certainly hasn't come
around yet that's all just natural so
this is how quickly the animals can
graze down the grass anyways let's go to
Ralph before his bird flies away
well uh now that we've seen a couple of
kingfishers now but this one is just
sitting so perfectly for us in the light
that I've just changed to the opposite
end and now we've got him hit first and
so I thought it would be nice just to
stop and watch him because he's quite
comfortable there on that branch and
looking like he's looking for little
insects as well and so don't forget the
question about the bobbing head if there
are any answers send him through Brigid
that's an interesting one bubbling the
head helps to move the hear the the food
down the crop I'm sure that it would but
I'm talking more about when they
actually spot something and then they
bob the head up and down and sometime
and also from side to side a little bit
sir
right mr. Tuvok you are absolutely
correct they do
Bob the head up and down and side to
side to increase the depth perception of
the target that they are looking at
because of the type of vision that they
have it's all about cones and I forget
the other one that's inside the eye as
well but you've got a number of cones
and it's ossicles as I forget the other
part but it depends on how many numbers
of those that you have now the birds
generally have a very good far distance
and extreme distance but then they can
tell very well the depth
so they Bob they hit up and down and and
a little bit from side to side almost
triangulating the target so that's why
they do it and lizards do it as well
obviously birds have evolved from
lizards and basically flying reptiles so
that's why they both do it very good
long distance vision but not a very good
judge of depth and that's why they do it
you will see birds of prey doing it and
you'll also see kingfishers doing it
when they're sitting on a branch and
once they see a target they start
bobbing up and down and little bit Rathi
left as well just working out exactly
how far away from them it is because
they need to plan their attack and this
one obviously seeming quite relaxed the
one previous was a little bit more
actively hunting and was bobbing his
head a head up and down and obviously
working out the little targets now if he
listened at is a little pill spotted owl
at calling
Aaron in New Zealand you say that the
sacred Kingfisher is called as such
because the Polynesians thought that it
controlled the waves that's very very
interesting indeed so the sacred
Kingfisher of New Zealand was thought to
control the waves I'm sure because it
was around the water so regularly
net and probably so good in the water as
well we'll start now for me rusty we're
gonna continue on now look for any other
birds here in the thickets and any
animals that might pop out as well
but it seems Steve has found you an
animal that likes staying in this
thickets too we have found some animals
finally we have done a loop after loop
after loop and I got back into the area
of Gallagher pen I was going to get off
and go have a look and unfortunately I
encountered some guests sitting on the
deck so I decided it was best for us to
just leave so we will maybe go back
there after dark and hopefully get the
movement of moody but at the moment
we've got a big male kuru via Taylor
waterhole now big male kudu over there
with some Impala behind it's good to see
the depth or the size difference between
them there's still a little bit of
rutting behavior going on with some of
the mail in parlors but isn't that a
magnificent specimen of the kudu he's
got lots and lots of ox Pickers on him
well-spotted outlet calling in the
background if you can hear it and in the
dryer duct dam itself we have got herd
of zebra feeding on the short some of
its short grass growing in the mud and
some of it quite long juicy grass yeah
they are Betty the zebras are Archaea
and feeding on nice sort of luscious
grass that's growing out of the pan
itself you can see it's quite green all
sorts of beautiful things in there Todd
for me to really tell what species you
can hear the owl in the background
there's even some kudu down here as well
in the dried-up dam feeding on the small
forbs that would be growing in and
amongst the grasses that you find out
yeah there we go you can see she's
ripped up a little creeper of sorts and
as I was saying this morning kudu are
not grazers at all so if you see them
with the head to the ground they are
feeding on small forbs or flowers
they're not feeding on on a grass beyond
dicotyledons so to lift plants when they
come out with the seed they've got two
leaves as grasses are monocotyledonous
only one looking quite healthy in fact
you can see her her rump is very very
good Julie you are in luck Craig is
going to pan to the right and we will
see the little zebra foal just the top
sort of topper Aatish of the screen
Craig's going to go into it now
here it is not feeding like the other
zebra or is it oh there we go but
probably still reliance a lot on milky
from mum here we go a little bit excited
jumping up and down so reliant on milk
from mum so not feeding too much at this
time wants to play now come on mum put
your head up
zebra Falls can be the cutest little
things in a few months ago you saw a
couple of them behaving very
interestingly with us jumping up and
down galloping around when you drinking
mum's milk you don't need to feed on on
the grass and it's a it's a never-ending
battle for zebra to keep themselves
nourished constantly feeding constantly
feeding with their heads down but like
the kudu that can feed our tear in the
open and then go and sit in a shady area
to ruminate at the zebra they discuss
the dung of the rhino and hippo this
morning constantly feeding both have
their advantages and disadvantages
mmm baby zipper is very cute so even
though this water hole is dried up they
still benefit for the animals those
forbs and grasses that are growing have
attracted them which means that it's a
very another attraction for for some of
the Predators even though it's a dry
water you could still get something
coming through to to take one of these
zippers down well one of the Kudo but
they're out in the open feeling quite
relaxed there's a whole lot of them
they're all over the place tis in parlor
Ayana around the corner as well so
strength in numbers someone is paying
attention so you can feed with your head
down in safety they are the one year old
man in parlous and we are going to stay
here with these animals for a little
while longer and see if anything happens
and let's go and see if Taylor's got
anything more interesting to tell you
about the camp we do just sitting right
at the top of this buffalo thorn that
has been beautifully manicured by I
think the elephants and probably the
Impala and kudu that hang around here
and all the way on top of that tree
those birds that are flying those are
all besides the bright blue one of
course are a southern gray headed
sparrows and a cape glossy styling
that's joining them
I suspect that they've decided to sit
all the way up on top of those thorny
branches just like that squirrel was
doing earlier just to catch the last of
the afternoon rays
I'm sure that's going to warm them up
quite nicely and sunbathing is very
important for Birds did you spend a lot
of time doing it always in the morning
just as the Sun has risen although you
see monkeys doing it to lots of the
different creatures well and then of
course in the afternoons it doesn't look
like they're doing much foraging at the
moment and they're very gregarious so
you often see them in big flux on the
ground looking for seeds sometimes they
eat a bit of fruit when it's available
and I'm sure that the interval on the
odd insect when there's a chance to but
predominantly feeding on all the grass
seeds so you'll find them in these open
areas
and and it's not uncommon to see them
with lots of other birds - very nice no
Clifford
you've asked how do animals react to
potential natural although all the
natural disasters so maybe like a big
fire or a flood well luckily for four
birds they're gonna have to abandon
their nest if they do have any and they
will there's absolutely nothing that
they can do
that's another starting that's the
virtual styling they were just flying
down into the distance and they're going
to do just what that's starting at
they're gonna have to fly away so birds
are really lucky they can escape things
floods and not all of them I think it's
Jonah on a hand there Darby are you sure
okay well I tried you saw I was trying
to be a gentle lady anyway basically
they'll just they'll just often go I
said if you're if you're a chicken you
can't fly it you're gonna and probably
not make it but for natural disasters I
don't think it's the birds are the ones
that aren't worrying about it's often
the reptiles and sometimes mammals get
to trap too and so yes those it's a huge
problem for them always feel sorry for
tortoises and and lizards and things
like that they can't escape fire as
quick enough that aren't as fast maybe
anyways I think I can actually hear
Steve's voice just down in the distance
I wasn't even speaking she must have
telepathy so here we've just moved a bit
further forward not sure if you can hear
the oxpeckers they're having a feast on
the back of the zebra the male Impala
calling in the background a very strange
gurgling sound see the youngsters
decided it's had enough it would like to
lie down and it often happens they get
quite tired you know they're not the
ones feeding so they've had their milk
nourishment for the day and they get a
bit tired they want to lie down and it's
perfectly normal you often get mums
turning over it watching out quite often
in a zebra hood individuals at a time
will lie down while others stand and
watch they have to sleep have to
physically like us put their heads down
and nod off for a while so as to
maintain their brain processes minimu
when zebras are born and the mother
generally goes away a little bit from
the herd and then apparently the mother
and the youngster imprints their
patterns on each other so they recognize
each other's pattern and then also the
smell so whether it's just the pattern
or just the smell or both I mean
obviously we can't know for sure but at
least one of those seems to work quite
well because even when they're returned
back to the herd the youngster can quite
easily identify a mum and vice versa so
very important for that early stage for
them to spend that time together and
then mum is never too far away from the
youngster and there's a little bit of
playing happening now very tactile
animals live where they love touching
they loved playing if any of you've ever
played with a horse or know much about
horses you know how much horses like to
touch and feel each other and a zebra
herds for example you get the stallion
and then the stallion starts off when
he's quite young with one female and
then he might they might have a fall
together and then as he starts getting
more mature he gets a second
a third and a fourth but you generally
see you know stallion getting between
maybe 4 and 10 females in a herd
obviously it depends on on their age
their status
sometimes a male gets killed and then
his females are all up for grabs and
then a local male can sometimes just
adopt them all himself so he can almost
double his numbers in just a day for
example if a male disappears because the
females need a male he he helps in
protecting them
he helps in fighting off unwanted
attention from other males and they
spend a life bond together so death do
us part you could say and he releases
his youngsters his females is juventus's
from time to time to other males that
are searching obviously he needs to
challenge them a little bit but it's not
a very aggressive challenge almost like
a father sizing up the prospective
husband for their daughter in human
society I suppose sometimes it can be
more aggressive than others really
depends Ashley zebra are a bulk grazer
so they can feed on quite sort of bulky
sort of nutrient poor grasses but at
this time of year they'll be selecting
as juicier grasses they can zebra able
to crop the grass so they've got two
teeth on the top and the bottom of the
jaw of the front of the jaw so they're
able to quite easily mowed the grass
down so they will select the juiciest
and the best grass as they possibly can
this time of year in line with all the
other grazers and that but they're able
to chop quite tall grass we've all the
best feed on a grass that zebra have
chopped down so the Valle de beers to
Germany for facilitated by the feeding
of the zebra so they'll feed on very
similar grasses but zebra able to feed
on longer grass up in the Mara you see
it very tall grasses every crop it right
down and that new growth gets sort of
fed upon by by the bull the best but all
animals will feed on as best
nutrient-rich vegetation as they can but
it's all got to do with the size of the
mouth zippers mouth is equivalently the
same size
of all the best and maybe even a water
back so water back and the zebra are
quite bulky feeders and of all the best
selectively bulky but you get something
like a rhino or a hippo that's got an
enormous mouth and very difficult for
them to select what they feed so they
just just gulp it all down whereas the
zebra be as selective as they possibly
can with the tools being their mouth as
they can be but there are benefits at
having teeth in the top of their mouth
so they're able to chop it right down
hmm take care that's an interesting
question
very interesting question I have no idea
take you wanted to know why the body
stripes are vertical and oh yeah
and the leg straps horizontal I think
it's just the way that they're being
painted you know it's just the stroke
goes from left to right I have no idea I
think it's just the way that they the
way that it works at it kind of acts as
a blur together so the legs not
necessarily as a sort of optical
illusion II as the body is but when
zebras move together that up and down
pattern of the body facilitates a very
nice flow and confusion tactic which
works very very well when they're in
large numbers when they're on their own
standing the outfit it doesn't work very
very well but why the leg straps are
like that I have absolutely no idea
there's a youngster still trying to get
some milk
Gary yes they will try they will try to
fend their Falls against predators
especially the stallion the stallion
will try and protect the entire herd
against predators sometimes at their
detriment and often when you can
actually tell who the stallion is if you
approach a breeding herd or a family
harem of like this of zebra
the stallion will actually get between
you and his his ladies so without you
even noticing the size difference you'll
be able to see him quite clearly by the
way his behavior he'll trying to get in
between you and yes they will definitely
try and defend against their predators
it really depends on on on the situation
you know there's there's a limit to how
you can defend your youngster if it's a
pride of lions it's very difficult to
defend and then it's all for themselves
but one lion or a leopard most certainly
a zebra might turn on one of them and
they've got a very very powerful bite
and they can kick very very effectively
so I have seen male zebras chase
leopards off chase I eanes off I've
never seen them chase a line off but I'm
sure it happened but like I said it is
also quite a risky business trying to
defend your youngster and putting
yourself in harm's way but it is their
lineage it seems to be the boy there
doesn't it
Clifford interesting question well the
Zephyr has always been known as the
painted horse they've got a much weaker
back then horses they are completely
wild I know you get wild horses in the
world but are they indigenously wild I
don't know exactly how horses evolved or
I think they're mainly were in Europe I
think they were very similar sort of
animal a long time ago but through
through breeding through agriculture or
domestication we've harnessed the horses
we have today that are are not ponies
they're more easily get ponies but they
they're just a lot bigger a lot stronger
and a lot more physical and able to work
with what they're do so and these guys
have got stripes but they are the same
family they're very very similarly
related just continental drift many
generations many many many centuries of
domestication has led zebras to be what
they look like just like cows were
probably very similar to Buffalo at one
point or something similar to Buffalo
and they've been bred into the vast
varieties of cows or cattle that you
find these days this like Taylor was
talking about that sandpaper raisin
fruit only being very slightly fleshy
and more seed that's the same with
certain animals they've been bred to a
point where they now look the way they
do just like dogs are related to to
wolves some dogs you would look at and
think are you sure but indeed they are
it's just through selective breeding we
have these very interesting breeds of
today but I think at one stage zebras
and horses would have sort of diverged
from a very similar animal species
there's way too much similar about them
the digestion the sort of social
structure the way they fight the hooves
everything like that even appearance a
very very very very similar don't
actually know too many differences apart
from the factors that zebras have never
been domesticated and it's impossible to
get them to do what you want to when is
it when horses are able to be broken in
and used for for grunt work and for
riding and I think just through many
many many years of
domestication just like sheep sheep got
domesticated because those sheep that
didn't do well being domesticated left
and got eaten and those who did well
being looked after by man well
they perpetuated so we gonna go from the
open clearing of the plains to a tree
and Ralph with another bird burn away I
can hear him calling we had the bearded
would pick at doing a territorial
knocking on this dead branch and as I
say that I can just hear elephants down
in the valley with a very characteristic
the reason we stopped was because there
was a beer that would pick a doing the
territorial knocking which they normally
do on a big dead tree like that
sometimes it's a lid wood sometimes it's
a knob thorn but it must be a nice
resonating hollow tree and there was
another one calling from just a little
bit further on and that's actually one
of the territorial calls but the bearded
woodpecker is the only one that does it
and it's a good very sort of typical
sound that they make and that is not
them searching for food and it's
actually them calling to other
woodpeckers in the area and as I said
there was another one responding to it
so it was quite interestingly now I know
that you said I think it was to Steve
that you would like to see Tandy and
Columba well I've decided to make my way
into the area that she likes to hang
around and we're just driving along nice
and slowly and seeing if we can pick up
any little signs
now a durian you are asking if this is
really live and if you can ask questions
well you just have and I'm answering
your question which is absolutely 100%
we are live there is nothing staged here
this is the wild the bush in the greater
Kruger National Park of South Africa and
you can send your questions and your
comments on the hashtag safari live on
Twitter or on the YouTube live chat so
just click on the link and you can then
sin through any questions and comments
and obviously not all of them gets put
through to us as as we are the guides
with a lot of questions come through but
the questions that are most pertinent to
the subjects that we are looking at will
then generally gets in through to us and
especially if we are sitting with a
lovely subject like an elephant all like
we had there with the woodpecker asked
us questions about birds and woodpeckers
or if we sitting with an elephant ask us
different questions about that but we're
not going to answer random questions
about random things when we're looking
at something in particular so that's the
idea and we want to get the debate going
about different subjects in the wild why
did things happen what happens in your
part of the world etc etc so that's the
idea and well it's not about just us
telling you all the answers it's about
sharing and debating durian thank you
brilliant I say fantastic and if you're
a new viewer and you've just found out
about how to join us well I'm stoked
about that because that's just somebody
else that's gonna join us in the
mornings and the afternoons or you can
join us on a Saturday for the safari
live show which is a catch up of all the
week's happenings especially around the
Predators and anything very exciting
that we've had during the week and it's
just a two-hour show and that will then
give you a full recap of what we have
done during the week so if you must
the shows you can then catch up on a
Saturday and well I'm gonna continue on
towards buffers look waterhole but it
seems that Taylor is already at one well
not one that you would probably find out
in the bush right and seen as though all
the people that live with this house on
holiday might as well just scoop some of
the leaves art while we're here said to
you earlier that it was getting a little
bit windy and while we better keep the
pool clean so this is way on hot summery
days we play there is much I don't know
even know what what it is I mean told
that I'm not doing a very good job at
cleaning the leaves out of the pool so
we find all sorts of things in the
swimming pool we find frogs water
monitors and then once just behind me
there was a hippo that decided to walk
on in and so that was very very
interesting I don't think I'll be able
to get all of these these and I bit
tomorrow yeah when I come through I'll
just be back in here but this is the
cleanest I've seen the pool for a long
time sometimes you come here and there's
all sorts of things living in it
but anyways we actually came into this
wall this is the other accommodation
though we have had wild earth and
there's a pair of Scott South that live
in the garden some way and we've been
hearing them calling every night and
sometimes in the day as we drive past so
I think if we just scan the branches
we'll be lucky enough to find them but
something else that I thought was quite
cool and I talk about them often it's
the round-leaf teak except a much bigger
one now the only reason why this one is
as tall as what it is is because the
elephants can't get in here well
sometimes if you leave the gate open
then well then they do come on inside
but it's really really quite nice but
even the trunk is not nearly as big and
as it can get it's all quite as small
and probably not very old at all but I
have seen some monster around leaf teeth
and I'm sure they probably a few in here
there's lots and lots and lots of
different trees from sickle Bush - lots
of bush willows well no wonder yes
that's exactly the hippo that destroyed
the decking you can see this is actually
all-new
over here all these planks that have
been redone over here cause they're all
not the elephant but the hippo actually
broke them and fell through it's not
very high so any less than a foot and
eventually Brent managed to to learn art
but you can see in winter why lots and
lots of animals would want to come here
please can you say that all again for me
cuz ya didn't quite hear what came
through Oh No
Oh Hren tourists can't stay at this camp
because this is where we stand if you
stay here then we've got to sleep
outside and it's quite nice sleeping in
a bed at night and I love spending all
day out with the animals but I'd prefer
not to cuddle with a lion or an elephant
so you can't stay at Juma private game
reserve
you can stay in two camps you can hire
art Galago camp or we attend a lodge and
they're really amazing because they're
kind of like something's not quite self
catering that's wrong word to use but
you can choose what food what things you
want to eat and there chefs that prepare
them for you and it's beautiful maybe if
a big Steve down at the dab he can maybe
give you a sneak peek of Rio lodge if
you're lucky so stay tuned perhaps you
can do that for you so oh no apparently
Steve has left the dam but keep watching
o-ring will we'll have a little look and
sometimes you get quite lucky and see
all sorts of animals there's lots of
spider webs and things around here which
is really quite nice so I'm going to
stop looking at the spider webs and I'm
going to start staring up into the trees
now to see if I can find well a pair of
scrubs I'll say yeah I know they're here
but I'm going to send you to somebody
else who's not looking for owls
yeah well we're always looking for owls
owls would be nice
we had the pill spotted and potentially
even a barred eyelid calling earlier but
we were too engrossed in our zebra
conversation we have left the striped
animals and we are back on our quest
I've been in touch with Ralph he's
headed up towards bubbles of water hole
so we will go in the other direction
maybe even if we are not lucky with
anything soon we might make a little
mission down towards chitra for the
sunset
how's that sound Craig some Aramark
babblers that are just calling their
noise Elizabeth that arrow shaped mark
on the chest
hello magnetic behavior they're doing
the calling the group bonding as a move
through the vegetation in search of food
where's a unit well it seems like Ralph
has been lucky this afternoon at the
puffle sook it's cuz he was surprised he
has for you well look we've just had
this little young male elephant who was
really telling us and that he was such a
big man in charting the odds at us he
was really giving us a little bit of a
show putting his ears out and running at
us and now he's obviously realized that
we're not going to play that game and
he's now gone off and tried to catch up
with the rest of his family
but there's another couple of elephants
just off of the Rajah up in front of us
and mommy and a very small little coughs
just down there now I'm not going to go
too close to her because it's a very
small little cough and if she comes my
way well that will be great I might roll
a little bit forward since I just to get
us onto the ridge of this kill but I
won't get any closer than that because
as I say she's good
small little cough there okay there she
comes I'll actually stop now and you're
gonna see the little cough I don't want
to disturb you and we can see her very
clearly here is the little one hello
looks like it's going for a drink still
suckling from mum obviously and she
looks like she wants to catch up with
the rest of the herd as a young male
obviously and we've had a lot of
elephants around recently that's been
very very nice we're all up and see if
we can get a glimpse of it from behind
before they disappear off into the
thicket just go nice and slowly that is
always the key with elephants don't
surprise them don't irritate them and
don't drive up and you know close them
up in a small space and it's generally
excellent viewing if you just obey those
small rules and give them the chance to
allow you into this space as I say mommy
with a little cough we will be a little
bit careful because we don't want to
make trouble but they can also sometimes
just move off because
there the guy it looks like they're
probably going to be catching up with
the rest of the herd which seems to be
moving in a almost directly northerly
direction so that's them I'm gonna
continue on now sins are those ones have
disappeared off into the bush we're not
too far from before hook Dam
so I am gonna continue on there's a nice
water hole there maybe some of them will
be coming for a drink as I said earlier
so we're gonna hit Oh since I'm more
behind you'll have to turn around that
way so I'm gonna get the next turn and
then we'll head back towards before so I
think those elephants might have just
come from there so I'm just getting this
next little ride and then we're gonna
hit through them they've probably all
just been down for a drink so we just
missed them I think but maybe there's
some more down there very often you have
some of the younger males I'd like to
linger around behind the herd and then
very often get left behind and you see
them then running through the bush as
they get told off or if they get left
behind and when they realize that
they've been left behind
then they try and catch up again with
with the rest of the group through there
I love watching elephants especially
around the waterholes it's always
fascinating
giraffe girl
the youngest elephant that I have ever
seen was it was probably about 15
minutes old I didn't see the birth
actually happening but I got there when
the elephant the baby was lying on the
ground and there was still the
afterbirth and all of that and mommy was
throwing sand on her own belly obviously
was the pain of having just given birth
there was a lot of blood around and all
of that as you do get when you when you
have animals giving birth so it was just
a few minutes old and it was beautiful
to see it almost had quite a pinky color
now sins are saying that he can see an
elephant is walking towards us
okay it's walking on the wall so we've
got some elephants in front of us that's
great news but I can't rise through the
bush
especially with elephants you've got to
always just be cautious in your approach
and we're actually approaching the dam
from a different side that I've never
come from this is quite interesting from
a new position there's a couple of
hippos that are normally in this little
waterhole just trying to get us through
very often come onto that side to drink
so it's actually a very nice way that's
to come down and spot them from this
side because that is a beautiful sight
look at the hippo just in front there's
some lipid smooth lipids elephants
moving off to our left as well and that
is beautiful like a thought and all the
bull walking around at the back
lingering awesome their egos we just
caught him at the end but I'm gonna wait
for him to come through on the ride it's
just behind those bushes there he's
gonna pop out in a second here he comes
look at the light on him now looking
yeah it looks like a bull and as I said
it's a quite regular quite normal for
the Bulls to be following up behind a
head and you can also see the sort of
the way that they walk as well
very relaxed some of the best viewing
animals when they're not in must that's
the problem
so we've obviously just missed them
coming for a drink but let's go forward
yeah looks like we've got a couple of
hippos still in the waterhole
this is spot them from the side
let's see I'll show themselves here we
are
hello hippos and this is one of the
spots that Tandy and salamba do like to
walk around I'm quite happy just sitting
here and waiting for a little bit and we
see if if she shows herself always just
got to put yourself out there and just
wait around but this it's um it's been
quite a long time that I've been coming
to Buffalo damn from about November and
each time I come there's always been one
bull in here and he was always quite a
nervous character and so much so that we
called him Scuba Steve because he would
just come up with his nostrils out and
not show anything else so it seems like
he's relaxed a bit with vehicles around
and he's also now got himself a little
companion that and she was also nervous
almost following his lead by just
letting her nostrils come out taking a
breath in going under the water again
and not showing themselves at all but it
seems like they've calmed down maybe
with a little bit of age and they've
relaxed with vehicles coming through
here I love it how they blow the yeah
almost like whales with a little bit of
a spray of water as well he looks quite
sleepy
millennia you say that hippos are your
favorite yeah I definitely do like
hippos and one of the favorite things I
do like about them as I've said many
times before is that they generally go
underwater they tell each other jokes
and that come up laughing it depends on
how good the joke was though because I
think Scuba Steve he still needs to work
on his comedy side because if you go to
chat with them very often there as soon
as the hippos come up they all do that
[Music]
and laughing at the good jokes that
they've got around a chip though so I
think yeah I'll Scuba Steve maybe he's
not such a funny chap he doesn't have a
sense of humor and well he spends lots
of time underwater what he's doing I
don't know but let's go on our way and
see if we can find a predator around
here somewhere we'll leave Scuba Steve
and his companion be I'm sure it won't
be too long and I'll be coming out of
the water and going looking for some
food that being a good grass nice
grazing area well I'm gonna continue the
search for predators all the way into
this evening I can't wait I'm sure we're
gonna find something exciting well we
found something it does a spider that is
terrified of us hiding in this little
leaf layer and that very pretty I don't
know what spider that is I don't think
it's a hairy field spider it must be
something else I think it belongs to or
one of the old web well in the old web
family sorry that's what I'm trying to
say and that was making its way when we
were trying to make it all look
beautiful with a golden light behind it
and it was just really terrified of us
it's the Sun it's a highway
obviously that's where it takes a bit of
shelter on a not so nice day when it's
too hot if it gets too cold all these
different types of things that's a very
good spot to hide away there in some
knees and that's such as two dead leaves
that it's sort of strung together or the
couple of pieces of silk it's got a very
intricate web that so it's even got some
some waving around basically where it is
and then the rest of the web which we
can't really see
- well on an ax and big an old shape web
it's very very pretty
it's a beautiful spider hasn't caught
Emilia perhaps it is preparing for the
evening perhaps that's the case how's my
audio now cursed I'm just trying to see
I'm looking at my pack okay well I'll
fix my mic in a minute then I'm not live
I need two hands for that but some very
very cool and I think it's going to be
quite happy tonight it's getting chilly
well it's getting chilly yeah Sun is
starting to go down I think there's
gonna be a couple of midges if we're
lucky
well if the spider is lucky I'll get
stuck on in there we go for a bit of a
ride and I've got a couple of other
things here firstly I think there must
have been some elephants that arrived in
English because I found this peanut
shell and we know elephants love peanuts
I'm obviously talking absolute nonsense
that's not true I don't know someone was
eating peanuts and has the shells and
all but I've got these two things first
one we're gonna have a look at is this
this is aloe vera all the ladies are
there they'd like to use sort of natural
skin products this is a great thing you
can see how it's sort of oozing at the
moment so if you've got any cuts or
anything like that you can just take
that very sticky sort of secretion and
you put it on your wounds and you put on
your skin if you get sunburn
pop it on and the other great thing and
it's how I stop biting my nails as a kid
my mom we had lots of loz growing
outside wall that were planted and then
there grew every night every way in
every morning she would put the aloe
vera on my nails like that and we'll
find go to school dare I bite my nails
there get a very bitter taste in my
mouth so that works really really well
in South Africa I put on my pants now
we'll see if it comes off oh no I have
to go wash my hands again then I found
this way there which is quite cool very
pretty I have absolutely no idea who it
belongs to it's quite a big for them and
put my hand I've just show you in
comparison it's quite large I don't
think it comes from the wing I think it
might come from the breast of the animal
or maybe on on the back sort of between
the wings and hashtag Safari live let me
know if you or any ideas what you think
it could be
it's very pretty though sort of a cream
color all those beautiful Browns well
I'll give you a little bit of time to
think and I look forward to hearing of
your suggestions
okie dokie well very exciting things
happening this afternoon Ralph with the
smallest elephant he's ever seen in his
life let's go and ask him Steve if he's
ever seen a really small elephant I've
seen very small elephants I saw that
elephant
shortly after gave birth at Tristan so a
few months ago it is the cutest little
thing ever it has no idea what to do
with this trunk thing it's just this
thing that it flips around it is just
too precious baby elephants just there's
something about them babies in general
really the baby elephants oh my word
they could melt anyone's heart and Jamie
had that sighting of that young elephant
that ended up falling down that little
little hill and then mom and someone
else rushing to pick it up yeah well
we're going to hit on singers are off
when two people suck we were thinking
going there but we communicated with the
radio just as well otherwise we both
would have materialized at the same spot
one of the benefits of the radio and
we're going to slowly make our way past
treehouse Dam and then down towards
chitra waterhole in the south east and
see if we can get some elephants of our
own and coming down to drink wouldn't
that be marvelous
you just hear that noise in the
background of a red crested kahan
they're coming into the breeding season
now and quite often that call is
followed by the suicide dive that their
practice they will fly up into the air
and do this backward somersault and then
pull out of the back of some sort just
in time to land on the ground and the
objects of that is they're very
camouflaged and the females and males
are spread out over quite a large they
flap they lie down and the reason for
that with it black on the belly
flying up like that is the ladies see
they hear the call and there see the sky
all over the place flying in and they're
come closer to the guy who seems to have
the most sort of daring dive hopefully
we'll see them as the winter months
starts to descend on us we will
definitely see them doing their thing
Mable Tuffy yes birds sometimes do swoop
down on our heads I have only ever
encountered that the other day buy a
pearl spotted eyelet that we're sitting
on a branch and came straight for my
head it's quite funny I think it has to
do with the fact that David was on the
back because everything seems to suit
for Dave I've been dive bombed by
blacksmith laughs wings and crown lap
wings but that they've got sort of nests
in the open clearing but I've never been
dive-bombed by any other bird from a
nest but it does happen does happen I'm
trying to think of some examples but
quite often you can actually stress
birds up I go and close the nest and
they'll go away and can abandon the nest
so it's not ideal to fiddle with birds
and their nests because if they feel
like their clutch has been compromised
and there's not enough time left in the
season they won't lay another egg and if
their feeders been calm or bars they
might not come back so it's one of the
reasons why in the breeding season we
don't play bird calls more than once at
a time you could really stress the
breeding pair up and you can cause them
to abandon their chicks and even the
eggs so very important ethical very
important ethical sort of things to pay
attention to there if you just walk
around playing bird calls all the time
not good not good
especially for a breeding pair
pray give me and dive-bombed my bed
Craig's been dog-bone by stylings they
are quite sort of sort of in-your-face
kind of birds so your stylings in the
karna bird that would do that but I've
never been done by styling but I can
imagine them doing it for Kyle drongos
the karna bird that would chase you away
most definitely well talking about birds
Taylor has got an answer for you on the
filler
I don't have an answer at all I'm still
very confused as to what feather I was
looking at but Karstens going to give me
an answer now
someone is guessed correctly I think I
must try remember this Larry you said
that that feather was from his one left
back wing I was sitting up on the second
tree from it was from a pill spotted
allas yes something along those lines at
10:00 p.m. last night
that's amazing congratulations you
wouldn't Airy that's exactly what
happened are you watching me I think
Cameron's around yeah no I'm just doing
very funny there might be a little bit
too big for a spotter poles but I doubt
it but I liked your joke though I liked
your joke so we've got some tracks here
now I'm actually trying to think David
maybe they're lying tracks you know why
I say that cause look here see we've got
small these ones are these are
definitely cat tracks you can tell
because you can see a very very clear
that translates to the back pad and then
of course we've got the toes I wonder if
this wasn't the sticks pride because I
know they've got fairly young cubs mmm
initially I thought Leopard I thought uh
okay he's been looking here named I saw
this one over here this footprint which
is massive and I think I think this is
from the sticks pride they're in an area
where we don't normally drive I mean
unless you've got to swerve out to avoid
hitting something and so they fairly
undisturbed in terms of tires and stuff
like that but you can see how the track
has been destroyed look at that complete
side of is actually looks like an
parlour or something as actually stepped
into this lion track and to me this
looks like a big female footprint day
you can see some more toes but the back
of the track has completely worn away so
when were they here - morning's ago
yes two mornings ago the sticks pride
were around there eat a wildebeest so it
obviously came around that way and then
walked all the way towards again
pad okay so we have any more guesses as
to what we think that feather is we have
I put it in my pocket some way here we
go
okay child of the universe you said an
owl and joy from your young Kong Hong
Kong I'm so terrible today you said from
an Aramark Babylon I don't think an
Aramark Babel oh they're sort of more
brown in color and than anything and a
bit more gray and Charlie the universe
I'm just trying to think what although I
don't think this is from a spotted eagle
owl they're quite mottled I don't think
this would be from ovaries eagle I'll
either I'm wondering if it's maybe not
from a night jar that's actually very
pretty
I'm just trying to think oh yeah I know
it's all such it's quite a big feather
maybe a night jar I have absolutely no
idea it's a very pretty feather though
we'll take it back to camp and also ask
Steve and Ralph and see what they have
to say but your guess is as good as mine
because I found it wedged on a tree so I
don't know if the wooden just blew it up
they will the bird flew through those
branches losing a feather it was quite
an Armour and Paul you said a hornbill
now I can see why you would have guessed
hornbills because they typically have
this sort of white put those spots all
the way down there back with black but I
don't think so I don't think that that's
come from from a hornbill I'm thinking
I'm thinking a nocturnal bird of sorts I
don't know why just those very muffled
colors or ground-dwelling bird of sorts
is a very sort of grounder maybe it's
from a Franklin hmm I don't know who
knows we'll try and figure it out
together
we'll keep guessing no maybe my pocket
is gonna be the best bet okay we're
gonna start heading towards the west
Andrew and then slowly to the western
corner of the open plains and see what
we can find and I have absolutely no
idea who I'm sending you to across next
well everyone I'm just backing up
slightly because we've got a very big
breeding herd yeah and it seemed like
they were just coming straight towards
where I was parked so I was pretty much
blocking their path so I'm just giving
them the paths that they want and in
other words giving them the right of way
so as long as we normally do that well
there's lots of them so we don't want to
particularly get surrounded especially
when we're blocking the path that they
were walking on but now everybody can
come past far past in front of us have a
little look some of them are little bit
nervous especially the ones with little
coughs hello mommy
this one's got very swollen memory
glands even though she's got a bit of an
older cough with her and they all seem
to be hitting our way now as I said I
want to get particularly surrounded by
big elephants with babies if they're not
in the mood for it
they seem to be quite relaxed now they
starting to feed the little baby is
having a drink for mommy so they seem to
be quite happy Erin the head of a femur
of an elephant hood is is always a
female yes its matriarch now these
elephants are all around us everybody so
I'm just going to be speaking with the
nice soft time because we want them to
know that we are friends not furs
we've got youngsters we've got elephants
of all ages here we've got mummies of
and they're all good little coughs hello
little one this one coming right in
front of our vehicle hello hello you
you're curious aren't you huh and here
comes a mummy with a little cough so
you've always very important that
they've got this space to move so yes
Erin the head of it of a group of
elephants is called a matriarch so it
will be one female that is the lead
and she will then sort of make all the
final decisions she's the one that
normally leads the group and tells them
when it's time to move off or when it's
time to stay and these elephants are
moving quite quickly I wonder if they're
also heading up to will towards where we
just came from
they're heading in the exact same
direction as those other elephants and
it's almost like they're doing a daily
movement from one part of the park but
on a sort of southerly side up into the
northerly side which is going up into
buffaloes look I'm just going to maybe
try and tune us a little bit I think
that's just about the majority of them
that's moved now oh but while I get us a
better position it seems Steve has found
one of those prehistoric creatures very
prehistoric we found ourselves at twin
dams and we found a beautiful monitor
lizard that is enjoying the last rays of
the afternoon Sun those claws very adept
climbers
beautiful creature in fact
a powerful predator they feed a lot on
their own kind as well very good sense
of smell when it comes to finding eggs
and birds nests one of the biggest
problems for crocodiles searching out
and finding the crocodile eggs Lily it's
pretty big I'm trying to think
Morse sort of work out the size just
over about a meter
a meter 2 meter 3 beautiful creature
there is another one a little bit off to
the left but not as good of you so we'll
stay with this one good but that's sort
of nice yellowish coloration one sort of
the body there a bit longer nose rock
monitors got less of that yellow and the
nose is a bit more stubby very powerful
that tail can flick very good for
defense
flicking to keep you quite hit you quite
hard and there's claws as well
guard your skin so not an animal you
want to go and pick up if you had the
inclination to do so
he suddenly looked a little bit more
intense didn't it like what you want to
come and pick me up no sir
we do not want to come and pick you up
but all the North pretty camouflaged
sitting there just on the bank need to
be with large Raptors flying in and
around martial Eagle being one of the
largest predators of these monitor
lizards the water monitor and the rock
monitor I've seen on many occasions I
mean look how camouflaged it is from
where we sit very camouflage so you need
to be if you've got the eagle eyes of a
large predator flying in the sky but
also that's why they are quite close to
the water if something big shadow looms
overhead they will quickly zoom into the
water where they're consumed very
efficiently side with swiping of the
tail paulius the speckles are very very
nice I do think they're very pretty that
quite a nice dynamic to the coloration
of the animal but obviously works very
well for camouflage whether it serves
any other purpose I'm unsure
dori I don't think so do you say you
want to know if they raise the offspring
I don't think they do
the only real sort of parental care
reptile that I can think of first of all
a crocodile will bring the youngsters
into a sort of a nursery but that's
about the extent of it and a Python will
sort of look after the eggs and even the
youngsters for a very short period of
time but other than that I think most
most reptiles are very non parental non
parental not of the parental kind but I
do stand to be corrected there if
anybody knows better than me there
please feel free to comment was a
phenomenal used well for digging
scratching up the crocodiles like to
bury the eggs on the bank so they'll do
very very well
my Liana lizards will sleep in all sorts
of different places they might find a
crevice under some rocks they could
sleep just under a bush we'll find a
cavity in a tree it's not really safe
for them to just sort of hang out there
on the bank but they'd probably find
somewhere to sort of secret themselves
away where they can have a proper little
sleep because as the night time starts
to cool down their body processes start
to cool down as well and they don't move
as quickly so if anything was moving
around at nights to try and hunt them
when the temperatures are colder be more
much easier to catch so sending
themselves to give them their last burst
of energy probably before they go find
sort of a favorite sort of spot to spend
the night but a no means would be the
same spot all the time and move and move
in relation to to the to their needs
food water but there would have to be
certain areas nearby bit logs or
cavities or holes in the bank that would
be needed for them
the evening we're going to move off from
here and see if we can get a glimpse of
the sunset from chitra waterhole but it
seems it's a Taylor has already lined
hers up we've got a different kind of a
sunset this evening this time we've got
golden backlit birds hovering around on
a termite mound now there's virtual
starlings and kick glossy stylings
yellow-billed hornbills and I'm not
really sure maybe a couple of Buffalo
Weaver's in there too but that termite
mound must be open somewhere where
they're all feeding I can't think of any
other reason why they'd all be down on
the ground like that and it's an awesome
little bird party very nice to see
there's actually lots and lots of
different types of birds all starting
together so I'm hoping the longer we
stay here the more we're going to see
and sometimes you can see exceptional
bird parties you know especially when
you get the gregarious Birds moving in
like the magpie strikes or even the red
bull Buffalo Weaver's all those southern
gray headed sparrows that we were
looking at earlier and they definitely
can contribute to the size of a bird
party but I don't think they're gonna be
doing much flashing of food like bird
parties typically do I think they're all
just gonna feed on the ground now it
must be termites oh and you can see
they're competing they're all chasing
one another around they're not very
tolerant of each other we'll just
tolerant enough that they're also chair
and feed but that is just absolutely
gorgeous of course um bushwalk we don't
have a big ambien to my cake we have on
the cars and I wish I was here in a
vehicle because the sounds that the
birds all the sounds are coming from the
birds is just amazing ok nothing you've
said McCurdy's birdies I like that
that's quite funny that's so stunning so
let's see if it can hear any sound
now I'm really hoping that Hill Cumorah
is going to wake up soon I'm sure he's
just sleeping supposed to camp hopefully
he'll wake up and threw a big rasping
soul that
we'll be able to hear that's so amazing
we'll keep walking on on these open
plains it's very nice yeah see what else
we can find
I'm just trying to think we did have an
in yalla but the in Jana has escaped us
and my plan was that we were going to be
below the Union and we were going to get
it silhouetted walking across the grass
that didn't happen that we failed in
Jana somehow got away from us we're
gonna casually just walk around see if
we can get closer to him birds maybe we
find a squirrel again silhouetted by the
Sun who knows Ralph has moved on from
his elephants I wonder what his plans
are next yes well as I thought those
elephants were very much on the move so
they didn't even stay for us to
reposition so I've moved on a little bit
trying to just find any sign of Tandy
and Kalama now we are in the area of the
quarry pan where she likes to hang out
which is right on our eastern boundary
and no sign of any tracks just yet but
sometimes you know it's actually not
always the best you have checks because
they can almost send you on a wild goose
chase and it was the other day when I
was with Sebastian all the lazy from
Ghana the Ghana Lee's Frenchman Cameron
camera operator we had been driving
around in circles following tracks and
we were quite frustrated because we
weren't finding what we were looking for
so I said to Sebastian today I'm not
following any tracks we're just gonna
look and while we land that finding
koumori and so sometimes you just need
to say that won't worry about the checks
because they can often lead you in the
wrong direction because the animal has
turned around in a circle or it's you
know gone off the road and come back and
done some zigzagging or whatever and so
you following those tracks and often
like I've said with my bastard and he
follows his nose and he follows the
scent but an animal could literally run
in a massive circle and come around and
be following him and he's following the
trail of the animal
and then carries on like that so yeah
not always the way to find an animal is
by following the tracks but it is
obviously a good indication that there's
an animal in the air yeah so for the
moment we haven't found any fresh checks
some but I'm not too worried about that
or know that Andy likes this area he's
been found here regularly and that Sun
is starting to dip towards the horizon
and we've actually got the moonrise on
one side I want to find a nice spot to
show you because we got the moonrise on
one side and the sunset on the other so
as we've got a nice spot here I think
since I will have to show you exactly
what I'm talking about because it's
beautiful
they're almost chasing each other here
we go
this looks like a good site that's the
one here we go what's that sensor where
do you start I start on the moon and
then you can go the other side to the
Sun so look at that it's heading towards
full moon it's maybe a night or two and
we're gonna have full moon and that is
on waxing gibbous as we would say the
phase of the moon at the moment so
anything over half moon is a gibbous
moon but it's a waxing gibbous it's
still getting bigger and now you can pan
across and show us the sunset seems oh
and it's very beautiful and that's one
side and the sunset going on down on
that side with some clouds in the area
as well always makes for very pretty
sunset and very bright at the moment
it's still got a little bit of a way to
go if I look at that what's that it's
probably about half an hour I would say
oh and I can hear heavy thunder I think
there's gonna be a thunderstorm tonight
so this is the calm before the storm
since I let's have a look at all of
these clouds it's booming now folks is a
lot of noise and it almost sounds like
this blasting going on big big
thunderstorm in the making here it's
very exciting and very uncharacteristic
as well because this time of year we
should definitely not be getting
thunderstorms it should be drying up
getting very dry not much rain and this
should be happening in summer full
summer we almost fully into winter all
the months without an R in them that's
and my you know sort of being the the
back end of autumn so we were just about
into for winter now and we're still
getting rain around so fascinating I
wonder what's gonna happen lots of rain
possible but speaking of water and
animals that love it
Steve has got some of those hmm the moon
does affect water affects all of us I
wonder how it effects elephants
considering we are 70 something percent
water elephants must be something
similar and if they have different moods
and different behaviors because of the
full moon I know I certainly do our
small family having a drink
a little one on the right struggling a
little bit with the trunk hasn't quite
got the tick eek down the others are
quite synchronised you can see that
they're synchronized
and the youngster is not quite sure okay
it's really funny when you see
youngsters get frustrated with the trunk
that they end up sticking their whole
face into the water
there's always funny I do love spending
time with elephants
there's lake you want to know what makes
it elephant herd a breeding herd and
basically females with the offspring
maker the breeding herd if you get and
the reason why we use the term breathing
hurtis because of the youngsters if you
just talk about a group of elephants if
you don't know the six there can be some
confusion for example if you see a group
of male elephant together we journey
call them
a bachelorhood because of their boys or
a bull with summit is Ascari and when
communicating meta but on a game drive
with regards to walking or driving Bulls
are jelly quite docile and quite easy to
approach whereas females with babies
because of the youngsters can sometimes
be or have different behaviors about
them because of the youngsters and they
need to behave in a certain way that
protects the youngsters and moves with
the youngsters and all of that so there
can be a little bit more stress darts
and can react to us a little bit more
differently thin then the Bulls can you
can see how there are two of them
they're stopped with their leg in the
air you see the ones but it's leg in the
air it's trying to make a decision right
now let's make a decision whether it
should be coming past here see it
delayed drinking as a youngster trying
to steal the water from it I want some
mum see she's the mum got the enlarged
mammary glands and she's definitely the
one in charge you can see are they all
moving with her
bulimia indeed the youngsters young
elephants for the first year and a half
two years a very very aligned to mum's
milk to sustain him not just for
moisture but for food while they start
trying to figure out how to use that
trunk they're getting majority of their
sustenance from the very nutritious milk
that mum provides but there's another
reason why there can potentially be
stressed because the mothers are having
to provide lots and lots of good feeding
for themselves
so that they can provide the milk for
the youngsters so that is another reason
why elephants can breeding herds can be
a little bit more funny than Bulls
important to understand breeding herds
and versus boots and they've just
stopped what are they doing they're
going to move off soon I am sure but it
seems like Taylor has decided to take a
load off
we just relaxing here on this brush walk
Steve we're not doing any work today
we're now watching the sunset isn't that
gorgeous and that's the most perfect
sort of anvil-shaped card don't you
think just behind it and as ralph
mentioned that he could hear quite a bit
of thunder brewing in a distance so can
we so perhaps that card is going to turn
into something a little bit but bigger
and well create a bit of rain it's
slowly coming in from the southwest
so I'm not sure what what it is bringing
thunder is going again I don't think
you'll be able to hear it with us though
and it's all starting to look quite hazy
but that's stunning
now good news guess what I heard hooker
Morey saw can you believe that that all
works out to plan us and as the Sun Goes
Down I hope that we will hear a leopard
saw and I did just down over there
we know it's aquamarine no he was left
there this morning somewhere in the
thicket and then during the day he
definitely come together go pan for a
little drink of water and now he's
moving so we're standing here on the
edge of quarantine we're not gonna go go
looking for him because they're starting
to get a little bit dark and I'll so
we'll wait I can actually hear a Ralph
racing on in trying to get as close as
you can to come and help us but he has
two routes that he wore
one of them is straight through camp and
basically right past the the room that I
came out of earlier today to start the
show oh he'll walk on the other side of
the drainage line and then come out past
the tent and James's little little cabin
and then go this way around so you're
just gonna keep an eye out and scan
around here and well hope that we can
hear and saw once more but I can hear a
Ralph coming in hot you're not wasting
any time
I agree Paula let's find a leopard let's
do it I'm gonna try and wave Ralph down
when I see him maybe you won't even stop
I'll just dramatically point like that
but I think what he should do is go and
check Gallagher oh maybe just pop onto
Gallagher shortcut just to check a
little bit and we'll stand by here and
see hopefully birds will help us or will
either just physically see him walking
around then he's not too far away right
Steve is having all the fun today with
lots and lots of different animals and
it seems like the hippo is entertaining
him
always needs to talk about the hippos
when at Chitwood waterhole they are
always a bundle of joy and this group of
youngsters has been splashing around
scaring the egyptian geese having lots
of fun James is talking about him last
night
and how many I think he said they were
twelve twelve youngsters
Oh formidable looking creatures aren't
they
for those of you who have not been
informed mr. James Hendry has left for
Johannesburg this morning this afternoon
he's flying off to the Caymans for the
grand opening of dive live not sure
exactly the dates and then he's going to
enjoy himself some time in New York I
believe 2nd of June is the opening and
then his hence enjoy some time in New
York followed by a some off time darn
back in South Africa well-deserved leave
not sure if he told any of you out there
but if he didn't it was a nice silent
disappearance probably hear the
cacophony of Egyptian geese all around
us have grown quite drastically in
numbers since I arrived here in January
to see the waves by the hippos created
there Cathy ah don't know any jokes and
if I do did I'm not sure if the hippos
would understand
you know maybe in about 10 15 minutes
they will start laughing probably at
anything we say
okay they're too busy playing with each
other to be listening anyway I've
spotted some of the water bucket coming
down there Craig to the left we'll
probably be able to see them in a moment
coming down just between the trees up
there you can see a youngster there is
one of the youngsters two of the
youngsters they are growing so quickly
another Egyptian goose in the foreground
feeding they're following Mumm Mumm is
somewhere there saw her before there she
is
this lovely thunder in the distance
I'm not sure if you can hear that it's a
rumbling quite far off to our South Mina
moon no hippos cannot survive without
water they've evolved to live in water
and if they are not able to sort of
saturate their body every day or
submerge themselves they will dry out
and it will lead to their death not only
do they need to drink water like all the
other mammals and animals we see around
they physically have to get themselves
wet so yes and they would not last very
long it's one of the sort of the
downsides of being hippo as well evolved
as there are and how many adaptations
they have that I've sort of pushed them
forward in the evolutionary perspective
the one that holds them back is their
dependency on water without which they
wolf their skin will desiccate in the
try art and I don't actually know how
long they would last without the water I
wouldn't say to be too long they can
walk quite far so if a waterhole does
dry out they will move in vast distances
in search of another one
well it seems as if Ralph has stolen my
thunder well thanks to Tyler for giving
us the heads up that we had a leopard
calling in the area so we raced down to
races she said it was coming from and
surprise surprise it looks like we've
got hookah Maury so wonderful he is now
sleeping out in the open and one of the
only times that you find a leopard very
easily when they're out on the road so
Thank You Tyler
much appreciated I have and I will
return the favor in future and that is
important between guides we need to
share the knowledge and share what what
is going on around us especially if
you're out on foot you hear it much
easier than when you're driving around
so if you can tell one of the vehicles
that is something happening close by and
they can quickly race there well that's
exactly the kind of clues that we're
looking for it's nice to see is poor
pads from this angle as well beautiful
and I'm sure it won't be too long and
he'll be getting up I don't know if he's
drunk already
oh hello he's sitting up now so you can
see that very clear three three spot
pattern on his whiskers and that's now
confirmed for me I just looked at him
and as we arrived and it looked like him
but now it's confirmed that spot pattern
of three three he is a good-looking cat
is me a little bit irritated with the
flowers around and everyone I am just
excited as excited as you are to see who
Camry
I've been looking for him for a few days
and just missing him so I'm glad I
finally caught up with him now as well
I'm sure he's probably come out from
sleeping some
nearby Steve said earlier at about lunch
time he heard monkeys alarm calling near
to the Gallagher lodge sort of but
towards for Taylor dam but he said it
was quite quick so I don't know if he
just made a brief appearance and then
the monkeys couldn't see him anymore and
but I'm pretty sure that were they were
alarming at him and now
Tyler's picked up on the rasping that
he's been doing so he's obviously been
sleeping somewhere in the thickets here
and pretty difficult to find him when
they like that and then now as the sun's
gone - towards the horizon starting to
get a bit cooler he's decided to come
out I don't know if he's been for a
drink already and he's come down here or
if he's still gonna go for one but he's
right near together got pan so there's
every chance we might get him going for
a drink but for the moment he's still a
little bit dizzy looks like he's still
got half a full belly but well that's
gonna be asked for the rest of the
evening if we can keep up with him but
it seems like Steve average Chitra has
got one of those very pretty birds
we have got a magnificent bird in the
name form of the saddle billed stalk and
it is a male you can tell that by that
little yellow spot just under the chin
beautiful pink needs the purpose of
which I have no idea
Greg why do you think they've got pink
knees so strange isn't it pink feet pink
knees because you're doing that often
the daily grooming process the preening
birds will do this every single day a
very deliberate cleaning of the feathers
especially the flat feathers zipping
them back again any Barb's that have
come undone
a little bit of a daily scratch
Marya is a very cool-looking bed it's
one of the the large stalks we find
around they are very well then I think
they're regarded as as threatened or
near endangered
there's not many breeding pairs left in
the Kruger National Park area they're
very easy to identify by the color the
name saddle build stalk you can see that
yellow on the top of the beak looks like
a settle on top obviously
Milana no they're not related to
flamingos flamingos are very unique
species on to their own stalks are very
different to I I'm trying to think now
the differences really I mean that the
flamingos is a bird that's able to to
sort of the double opens the opposite
way it's the early bird I know that's
able to do that they're a filter feeder
and their beak actually opens at their
bull opens top the top B curves away
from the bottom beak or other than most
birds the bottom moves down so very very
interesting and then behavior how they
walk around and the salt pans and they
filter feed all of different types of if
they're the greats of flamingos they're
feeding on on the phytoplankton and if
there are the lesser flamingos they're
feeding on zooplankton so they're
feeding on different very small
specimens in the vegetable in the salt
pans and that's also it gives them their
pink coloration the water buck Emily
just behind as they climb up onto the
termite mound there Craig Oh mmm
lots and lots of little youngsters and
they are feeding on the juicy juicy
grass provided by the termite mound
those little Yanks is there probably
nearly weaned it started to feed more on
vegetation and they're learning that the
best sweeter stuff is actually on
termite mound which is a good good thing
to learn from an early age are nutrients
good quality food
and if certain cat was nearby I'm sure
one of these young water buck would
feature very high on his menu it's going
to see what Ralph thinks yes well we
still with a very sleepy cat yeah he's
just having a look around every now and
then and then just flops his head back
down a little bit of stretching going on
which is always a good sign that he
might go on the move just now and also a
bit of rasping that happened earlier I
haven't seen him or hit him rasping
since we've got yeah but that's a good
sign that he might be getting ready to
go on the move but his arse is still a
little bit heavy now Victoria it was a
new viewer thank you for joining us and
thanks for sending your questions for
you
the spot pattern I'm talking about I'm
gonna ask Cynthia to go in nice and
closely there because leopards can look
very similar indeed and if you look just
above the whisk alarm name you've got
three dots that are just to the left on
his right but as we looking at the
screen just to the left of his nose of
his nostril you've got three dots there
at the top that first little on above
dots one two three and you see that and
on the other side of his nostril you
will also have that so on the right hand
side but we can't see it at the moment
so if we've got lipids that are there's
no major characteristics about them that
we can't tell maybe we've got half a
tail or he's got half an ear or a very
big scar on his face then we use these
spot patterns so we got very close in
there and who Kamui this one in
particular he's got a spot pattern of
three three so three on the left and
three on the right and if we go to ting
Ghana which is another individual male
that we've got here he's got five five
five spots on the left five spots on the
rod and there's another there's a female
young female that likes
hang around ho Kamui and then I'm sure
do Lou and she's got also far five spot
pattern so you can have all sorts of
different ratios you can have a 5/3 you
can have a four three or five four and
all sorts but it's just a closer or a
more in-depth way of being able to
identify individual lipids especially if
you're not being able to see any of
those unusual characteristics that would
obviously lead you quite easily to an
answer as well so that's what we use in
terms of spot pattern obviously we can
also look at the different rosettes that
form different patterns on the side of
them as well because sometimes you get
like a little smiley face type look
especially coming up towards the
shoulder part over there you can have
different little patterns that you could
then if you take photos or if you take
screenshots off the video that we're
busy giving you now you can then also
make as little patterns that would then
lead you towards which individual it is
now we're not going anywhere
and we're going to set you out with huka
Murray and see what he gets up to I'm
hoping he might even go for a hand I
think that sounds splendid but look at
how the sky is changing there is
definitely something brewing out this
evening I don't know what it's going to
be what it's going to turn into if it's
going to be you know maybe just the
run-of-the-mill thunderstorm or quick
downpour and then off it goes or if the
rain is going to settle in now I know it
was supposed to rain this morning in
fact remove but the rain moves on and
everything and Rickson even told us that
it was pouring with rain and through
vakani which is not too far from here
and he says we better be well I'm better
make sure that we you know don't get
rained on we're all ready and then it
didn't it cleared and then the clouds
came around again and we've had a
beautiful day and they said we played
cricket outside obviously we know one
plays indoor cricket I'm not here in the
wild but it was um it was interesting
there's a little bit overcast but it
definitely didn't feel like it was going
to
reign at all now unfortunately with all
this cloud cover it means that the light
is disappearing a lot quicker and then
we would have hoped I reckon the fellas
on the vehicles I'm gonna have to put
the infrared lights on sooner than they
would have thought to it so we're gonna
probably head on home now get away from
the storm and well we'll see you
tomorrow morning I won't I'm sleeping in
bits and somebody else that will see you
tomorrow morning as Steve and he's with
the water back
mmm-hmm blank sailor get out of the
storm it seems to be coming quite
quickly from the south we must start
moving back ourselves but this water
back male is very interested in that
female and the kids are watching on even
their word sir mounting in the kids a
moment ago does they were doing what
daddy was doing or trying to figure out
what game dad was playing he's been
following that female since since we
first saw them he's tried to mount a few
times but she keeps moving away you
clearly see the intention
see I tests with the leg underneath
quite characteristic for water buck a
lot of other species do it as well such
as sable Android antelope
there we go the youngsters are they
wanna play too
interesting the color difference between
some of those youngsters there with the
age well the only a month or two in
between but the color match different
from that very three Tony brown and
she's still got it on the forehead to
that very gray coloration that male
wants to be part of the action as well
uncle Freddie I think that's a good
question I mean I've seen domestic
cattle whenever they see a storm
approaching lie down and sort of shelter
the ground underneath em so they've got
a nice dry spot to sit I don't know if
while animals seem to do something
similar I mean you do see Buffalo sit
down but it's just there's a certain
time of day when they start sitting down
doing the illuminations but I think
animals are aware on the storm whether
they'd do anything about it from time to
time is hard to say but you know there's
nothing really they can do about it
anyway they're going to be caught in it
they can't decide to go put on a roof or
go shelter underneath some form of
carport carport or something so I don't
know it's a good question though
so I'm not sure I don't know if I mean
every now and again you see lions and
leopards looking up at vultures as
they're flying because the vultures can
attract them or guide them to food but
you never I've never noticed any any
animal kind of longingly looking into
the sky thinking wow that looks like a
cartoon character oh that looks like
something I don't know maybe they do
maybe they do well we're not we're not
watching I saw a monkey last night I was
off and our walks out of camp and I saw
monkeys sitting atop of a tree and I
stopped to have a look at him thinking
maybe he's looking at a leopard he was
just watching the sky and sort of
looking at the Sun in the distance and
that was you know provokes a few
thoughts in my head like is he actually
watching the sky is he is he like having
a moment with himself there you know a
little bit of a silent moment with
himself it's interesting not sure hey
Craig a let's move on the storm does
seem to be moving in from the south so
we're to start heading a little bit
closer to home where it will make it a
little bit easier here we go you can see
it looming a bit bit easier to to deal
with if we do does suddenly open up
Ralph who is quite close to home who
moved into the area we're working
earlier as stallworth Walker Marie let's
see if he's still sleeping
well he's got his eyes open but he's sir
he is still very relaxed just chasing
flies every now and then having a look
around flicking his ears
panting away not really doing too much
and why are we sitting here we're
hearing all sorts of bird laughs you can
hear the noisy natal spoonful we've got
the very chatty starlings and we've got
the odd chat graph and it's all heading
towards nighttime with these clouds
moving in as well it's gonna be quite a
dark night even though we did have that
almost full moon I think with these
clouds moving in ass gonna be a dark
night and so actually much better for
hunting for the Predators because when
you have that full moon that's very
light and the prey animals light or the
antelope they can then quite easily spot
there the or much easier should I say
they can spot the Predators then coming
in and when it's dark those are the best
nights for the Predators makes it a lot
easier for them because they can still
see much better than they enter that but
not so who can worry what you're gonna
get up to tonight Josh the leopard
stunts I've never had a leopard jump
onto my vehicle they have moved right
next to us they move right in front of
the vehicle they move right past us when
I was training students in a game
reserve not too far from here I had a
lipid that sprayed a bush that was right
next to our vehicle and you know we
often have these trekker seats in the
front and the student that was sitting
on the tracker seat
he got weight from the leopard spraying
on the bush next to the vehicle so
that's about as close as I've come to a
leopard jumping on the bonnet literally
spraying
the student sitting on the bonnet so he
will never forget it he will probably
never be closer to a leopard and he'll
probably remember that smell for the
rest of his life as well on these
particular things that happen when
you're out in the bush that you'll never
forget and well I'm sure that that
student and that was one of those
moments for him now who Komori is one of
these special animals as well that I
think he is also going to give me some
special memories and the times to come
still quite a newbie in this part of the
world I haven't spent too much time in
the sabi sands so I'm very excited at
the prospect of spending time with these
particular animals getting to know them
getting to know their movements
getting to know the different spots that
they like hanging out and where they're
hosting their kills etc and I'm quite
interested in this in this little
relationship that's blossoming between
who Kamui and should you lose now I've
just got some other people that have
also shown some interest in coming into
the spot so I'm just going to chat with
him quickly on the radio yeah you can
either come down on Google or you can
come down Galaga shortcut and then you
know towards Galaga ten but let me know
and I can try and direct Jean
okay copy no problem yeah there's
another vehicle on the way in with some
guests I think they're from Australia
they want to come and have a look at
these this beautiful Katya no he's
stationary just to the east of Gallagher
pen yeah is Lala Ramsey on the road
riding around yeah Marie that was a nice
little you only gave us as I say it's
not a bad thing to see him doing that a
little bit of activity because I'm
really thinking that he's going to be
getting active soon now we're going to
be swapping over to infrared or our
night-vision because we're losing light
and their sensors just swapped across so
that is the reason why you see it a
little bit black and white because with
the normal camera it's pretty much like
the prey species there's not enough
light and then you don't get to see very
clearly and we'd have to put the
spotlight on him which then does disturb
him a little bit and and the animals
around as well now what you seeing on
your screen is it's very much lighted
but we don't need to use a spotlight and
I actually when I'm looking at him with
my naked eye he could be totally in the
dark but you'll see him clearly on your
screen so sometimes every now and then I
might need to use my spotlight just to
relocate him asan obviously not if he's
lying down like this because we'll very
easily see where he is
but if he's moving around and and
potentially walking through the bush
then I just use the spotlight just to
relocate him and just to help since I
then put the camera on him what's the
infrared or not vision but for the
moment it's what we call a flat cat not
really doing too much and even with the
infrared you can see that as flies
buzzing around his ear make you know
that rain and storms can actually assist
predators because
it does dampen sounds noises and it also
does dampen smells so predators can
actually use rain and storms to their
advantage if they are up to going out
and hunting at their time but I know of
lots of predators that have taken down
prey in the midst of a storm as I say it
almost seems a little bit easier for
them so yes and they will go out and
hunt in a storm it's actually a good
idea and look at that instead of chasing
those flies which must be quite
irritating and at least now with the Sun
setting they should actually start
giving him some peace and in the next
half an hour or so and that's when
you'll probably also get up and be
active so all we can do is hope it
doesn't seem to be a very skinny and we
know that it wasn't long ago that he
killed a warthog that was with Taylor so
it's not as if he is starving but he
could go hunting
Kenny I don't think that lipids will
recognize their names
no and in fact I think it's just for us
as humans to be able to call the animals
different names but for them yeah the
names that we give them I don't think
they worry about that in any way
whatsoever so I know that it would be a
nice thing just to call his name and he
had maybe look up and look at us but
yeah and the animals out here there in
the bush and I think they just recognize
smells and sight of animals more so than
any kind of name because for them those
are the highest parts of the ha the
biggest sense is that they will be using
so for instance hukum or you will call
your ASP and you'll also mark the ground
and bushes he'll spray urine on on the
bushes and you'll also mark with these
claws on different branches and in tree
trunk 6 and so on lions are the ones
that do that the most but lipids can
also mark with their claws as well but
generally it's about that smell that he
leaves lying around with his urine so
other lipids that come through they'll
smell that urine and they'll know that
it's a particular a male that's in the
area or female and then they'll be able
to follow up through the smell mostly or
olfactory since and so that's what they
use the most and so for instance hookah
Murray has been following shadaloo a
young female around who I would say is
probably between 4 & 6 years old and so
she's a young reasonably young leopard
but he's been sort of courting her and
mating with her as well and he would be
following the very clear smell of her
around she's also been marking and she
does also rasp every noun in it's a
slightly different call to that of a
male not really as loud and not quite as
horse it's difficult to tell between
them unless you hear
lot of lipids cooling you can just tell
the difference between a male and a
female lipid rasp it's very difficult
though and also sometimes you can have
males that don't really want to be
shouting very loud so it can be a bit
softer
all right so let's just hope that hukum
already does and give us a show and at
least go for a drink well anyway that's
what I'm gonna sit here and hopeful and
we are meandering through the Milwaukee
drainage system which is a very nice
area to find something moving along I've
yet to find the cat or a leopard walking
down here but we've many times at their
tracks and this for continue up this is
probably where Alf is with cuckoo Mooney
further towards Duman lodge itself will
tell a camp itself so we hoping
something will pop out I've had the
uncle whom is in here the lion pride
we've had the Birmingham boys in here
their focus because this drainage system
goes all the way south down to my Allah
my Allah so it's quite a productive sort
of area and lots of animals will utilize
it nice and soft on either side of it is
a perfect habitat for all sorts of
animals on Bush walk this morning our
would have discussed it with us we found
those niala that were interested in each
other they were enjoying a little bit of
the long grass in the shadow of the
drainage system also lots of birds
ground nesting birds the impala are
moving through they can love this kind
of area Bush Bucky and obviously monkeys
and baboons would be frequenting the
tall trees in and around these systems
so very very important from an
ecological point of view
Josh I don't don't keep them off they
they come the Flies they come and I've
learned to just ignore them sometimes
you can't it just gets a little bit
annoying but you try and just ignore the
fly but the mosquitoes sometimes we add
repellents to our skin I'm not a big fan
of a day to keep them away but the
mosquitoes are only really a problem
after we've had some rainfall so as
winter draws nearer they should be
disappearing but we keep getting these
little bursts of rain which then leads
to an outbreak of mosquitoes again and
yes they do bite us but we do try and
avoid being bitten I have left my jacket
at home that's why I'm looking so Stark
is on my arms I had it attached to my
bag off to my walk this morning I took
it off my back to play some books inside
and I must have left it on my bed okay
well we are in quite a bad signal area
because of the drainage system while we
try and navigate these gremlins this go
back over to ruff
so everyone I'm just making space for
another vehicle that also wants to come
and have a look yeah I'm just putting my
nose in yeah get out of his way a little
bit more up there
there we go okay now we can see him
lastly just want to check that I've got
enough room I might need to go forward a
little bit
[Music]
okay here's it so obviously as I was
saying about the infrared obviously with
the guests behind us
I won't be able to see the leopard
without the spotlight so that's why you
seen that as well now now say me yes
you're right let's do pent when it's hot
they've also got a very high metabolism
so that means that the digestive food
very quickly but that makes them pent a
lot when it's cold
they don't pent as much and I've just
got someone on the radio answering for
me that's good so you see how he's
panting it is still a little bit warm
and as it gets a bit later you might see
the repents a bit less but they always
do paint a little bit because well
lipids have quite a higher metabolism
and if you've ever heard a lion can post
your tent at night which I have many
times and I've even come past me when
I've been sleeping on the ground one of
the first things that has actually
eluded me to their presence is the very
deep panting that they do like and
that's actually how I knew the animal
was there so it's actually a very normal
thing for predators and large cats to do
there's a lot of panting I'm just hoping
that he's gonna get up and go for a
drink rather soon malaika the the light
doesn't particularly bother the lipids
too much it's mostly the day time and
I'm also the diurnal animals that um and
really do get bothered by it so you see
there he won't look almost directly into
the light and not have too much of a of
a difference or change but you know this
is one of the small little things that
it's almost this all
that was very pretty a small sacrifice
in enabling people to be able to see
these kind of predators in their natural
habitat
it's he's gonna move now I think he
might go for a drink are you gonna go in
the thicket he might mark he's gonna
scratch that do a bit of urinating
possibly even a poo that's typical
marking behavior there there he's
urinating any mud
you see wipe his feet in at night and do
do that looks like he might just have a
little bit more and now I think he might
make his way up towards the waterhole
now the point I was making was that you
know people need to be able to see these
animals because they come in here they
pay a lot of money for tourism and it's
one of the small little sacrifices that
well it's a slight disturbance in a
small way but very very little but you
know what it enables these animals to be
protected in their natural habitat this
vehicle just gonna let's get up and go
but closer now everyone
I sure it's gonna go for a drink so
let's just back out yeah let's get up to
the water and watching there so yes I
don't want my my point to be
misconstrued what I'm saying is is that
there's a small sacrifice to be made
with sometimes with not a massive or
intrusive type of behavior with these
animals but with us being able to watch
them where is he is it off to the side
okay I wonder if he's gonna go back down
there I don't know if we're gonna even
be able to see him I think you may be
already been for a drink Larry is going
into the thickets they're heading
towards the lodge and we won't really go
into that thicket they're us of
stretching he might get a little bit
active now he's rubbing his nose on a
branch that's also part of marking
okay guys I'm just moving just to try to
relocate just to get us into a better
spot here okay so I'm just gonna try and
get in here closer but while we just
getting in here and see if we can do
that this hit you back on over to Steve
maybe he's been able to find something
else hmm it's very thick stuff that way
who koumori is so very difficult to
navigate with a vehicle very easy for
leopards are just mission through there
and bear in mind if he does go through
that towards the lodge and around
towards the Dan that's where all those
niala and couldn't Impala and the baby
zebra or whether they're still the same
area it's debatable they might have
moved off hearing him call would have
given away his position and definitely
put them on alert so we are we have
decided to come back towards the east
the storm seems to be south of us and
moving steadily west and we're going to
have one last-ditch effort today Sunday
for Tandy and salamba obviously we're
not going to shine on them if we find
them we do have the IR lights available
but this is the time of night where we
could find tündi maybe just on their own
moving maybe headed in and out of the
area that they had checks this morning
who knows I've had a rat once before
coming back and evening with Ferg behind
us we came through a little drainage
depression that she spent some time in
back when Scott was with us here
full-time darn and Juma and we generally
got her in this area for quite a few
times she spent some time just up here
as well as a few months
Josh I don't think there's any
difference in the color between man and
female what you do notice is the males
are a little bit bigger so there seem to
be a bit more stretched in my opinion so
the spots seem to be slightly my opinion
further apart so they almost seems to be
a little bit more gold to them than the
black so you kind of invite when you
first see a female in the man you kind
of see like a little bit more dark in
the female a little bit more golden in
the male but that's just my opinion
right now but they are pretty much the
same there's just the size difference in
each leopard is quite unique in their
spots in their coloration where they're
positioned and all that sort of thing
but they all look very very similar in
how they are and it's only facial
expressions and the spot pattern there
is a new Yala up ahead it's not blind
him you can have a look at him with the
IR light that works quite nicely he's
going to move off there the beautiful
evening
Yala booth it's not a breath of a
come starlings in the background closing
down for the night so we're looking with
the special light on the special camera
which enables us to see these animals in
the darkness so as not to bother them
with the spotlights this is the time of
day that the leopards like to move
around as you can see who Kimura is
moving
hopefully Ralph is able to find him
again
what antics are is he going to be up to
have another niala up ahead about to
cross the road a female well no wonder
scorpions are active all the time but
they do go through a sort of a form of
torpor where they're just slowed down
their behavior and they're a lot more
active in in in summer months being an
arthropod temperature is a very
important aspect for them in summer we
find the scorpions moving around a lot
and that's a lot of the time when they
do their mating but they can be active
at any time of year but it is
temperature related so we don't see as
many of them around now because they're
basically quite ambush in their
predatory ability they will sit and just
wait for something to come pass and then
come out of their rock or bark or
whatever it is that they might be hiding
and then tackle the food but they are so
well adapted that a scorpion can go for
like an entire year without eating so
you thought hookah Maria was patient the
other day he only sat there for an hour
and 40 minutes waiting for that warthog
to come out where a scorpion can wait
for a year
it's a long time it just made me very
hungry Craig how about you
now they'll very very well adapted to
water conservation heat temperature very
very well adapted ain't seen many
scorpions at my time here I don't know
while it is I suppose other places I've
worked I've had a lot more rocks a lot
of scorpions do do very well in rocky
habitats that's not the road I wanted to
take we walked up here today if we try
stay on the road shall I Craig I was
busy looking down that road just to see
if we could spots anything quite often
you see animals walking in the roads
it's always important to scan down them
as you drive fast and let's see how our
elf is getting on
if Okumura has managed to come out of
the thickets
well the other vehicles are watching him
is walking is going along that sort of
drainage sliding heading straight
towards via tiller damn so I'm just
anticipating where he's going and I'm
keeping in touch with those game viewers
as well
and I'm I'm just hitting out in front of
him so that he can head towards us and
we'll have a nice view of him as you as
he comes towards us and they've just
told me in my ear now he is on his way
exactly where I thought he might be so
it might be perfect for us just to hit
there in front and then we'll we'll just
come to the northern side of the voya
till again and also if you watch on the
damn cam I'm sure that you will be able
to see him coming past there soon but
we'll see him first and then he'll
probably go up just off of the side of
the the dry dam at the moment and he
might go up to where the water is next
to the dam cam and have a drink there it
it didn't seem to have a drink at the
Gallagher pen I'm not sure the awesome
other vehicles yeah but don't know if
that's leave but you can see that might
be me seeing on the DM cam
I am flashing my lot now just waving it
up and down I'm just looking for my
particular spot that I like to go in
here at waterhole itself so don't go
anywhere we're gonna watch huka moody
coming towards us beautiful hang on
and I'm sure he might even come through
here after he comes and pays us a visit
let's go through here and have a look
and Dixon one of the wonderful guards of
Gallagher Lodge he's just told me that
he that I did the right thing that he's
coming straight towards us I mean now
hitting you'll probably see on the dam
cam this is me coming towards you hello
yes I'm shining a lot towards you guys
yeah you know Moody
you know I think somebody just calling
me on the radio so I'm just going to
answer Ralph
Josh are you looking for me
you're welcome to take a stand by I'll
probably be here for the next 15 minutes
or so but yeah and then I'll my cry for
use microwave so long he looks like he's
coming out towards a voyeur tailor damn
itself so start making your way copy
that's great okay oopsie
we've just got to see when he comes
through takes cover off
text us when a chick have you still got
the visual on Okumura so we're looking
at frontier this is the direction that
he was moving but we'll come quite far
ahead of him
coppy sorry Aubry man I thought it was
takes ok so there's lots sight of him
there but he's still walking in there up
on the right now so let's um it's just
gonna have a look now Dorian the damn
cam is a permanent camera that is set up
on one of our little water holes which
is just off to my side here and you can
also get access to it
Kirsten can you tell me in my ear
exactly how they can watch on the damn
cab and I will tell you now once Kirsten
tells me
okay so it's gone to Wilders TV website
and there you can click on the damn cam
and then you can see live what is
happening here at the waterhole which
I'm just driving past it's just off to
my side and this lipid might also be
coming up to have a drink yeah quite
shortly so gone through the Wilders
website and then you'll be able to
access that and and it's one of these
wonderful spots that we often have
lipids coming past these hyenas
sometimes elephants and all sorts
happening and we very often get from the
viewers they're telling us what has been
happening here before we even get up in
the morning let's see if we can find
this guy again he's walking slowly
through the bush now Josh that's an
interesting question do lepers ever
catch fish well I can tell you something
that I've actually watched him doing
exactly that it was in the small little
water holes there's his eyes there there
is is coming
yeah I can see it's ours day there it
comes okay so we're probably gonna have
him coming out now just over here sir
there he comes so yes and I have
actually witnessed lipids catching fish
in small little water pans especially
when they start drying up and then they
start just grabbing them with their
claws because it's quite easy them you
know so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna reverse up here and get
ahead of him now that we know that he's
popped out see this grab his and
everything it's just running through
there you had a look at it
grab his Australian in front of him so
I'm just gonna back out and get in front
of him like I said we just wanted to
make sure that we hadn't in fact lost
him and it crossed the road but he is
now difinitely making his way we are
thought he was going to just want to
make sure so it was a big log via there
it is it was driven into it it's just
quickly spin around we'll get a nice
view of him from the face coming towards
us rather than his bum it's much better
that way isn't it you can get a nice
view on him from this side got to be
careful if you don't drive into an art
for coal because that would make us get
stuck
now Shamala thanks for your comment and
that you visited South Africa and you
guys are really amazed how you can
stream safari life well that's exactly
what we want to be doing because we want
to bring this kind of atmosphere to
everybody you know we're very lucky that
we can actually experience this life
ourselves but for all of you wanting to
get your African fix and your wildlife
fix we do this twice a day every single
day of the year so oh and I think I'm
feeling some raindrops now Kamui did you
feel that too and some rain starting
everybody big drop starting to fall so
that's heading towards the end of the
game Drive it might be just in time
Kamal either he might continue on and go
for a bit of hunting I'm gonna try and
getting in front of him again and
hopefully this ride will just give us
enough time to see this guy walk up
before he heads off into the bush need
to be careful like us if not just fall
in an artful barrel because then we get
very easily stuck and sometimes you
don't see these artful barrels until
you're in them especially at night when
you're driving off-road
a little bit ahead of fuku Murray but
also very mindful of the fact of trying
not to get stuck in a barrel let's now
get a little bit further ahead of him so
that he can walk towards us for but
longer jaja you're absolutely right oka
Murray is quite used to the paparazzi
and we're gonna get a nice close view on
him once again looks like he might be
heading up towards the dam cam or will
the the video is there yes look at that
the silent killer but he's a very
beautiful animal isn't he Wow also put
my spot on the list so that we can see
him a little bit better
there is a there is that's just put the
light just near to him not directly on
him just so that it doesn't disturb him
too much
that's nice almost bounce the light off
the grass onto him you know and then
it's not so disturbing other than
shining it straight in his face see he
still got a rather large belly hey I
don't think that he's going to be
chasing all sorts of things tonight
there's every chance obviously the
opportunistic hunters so they candy but
you know he's not starving so it's not
like he's going to be taking lots of
risks or chasing lots of animals down I
think he might be going for a drink hey
guys hurry up the Sade
now everybody Wow we were very lucky to
see Oh Kumari even if it is just at the
end of the drive and as I said lots of
rain coming down now we are heading
towards the end of the show I want to
say thank you to all the animals for all
the appearances that they're made
especially the elephants and the lipids
thanks to all the FC people thanks to
the cam ups thanks to all the other
guides and most importantly thanks to
you the viewers now please join us again
tomorrow morning for another Safari live
good night for now and goodbye